[Musique]
Henri Guaino bonsoir bonsoir nous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
je suis né en 1957 à Arles
je me sens
français bien sûr pour en salle et
Romain
voilà je suis né à l'ombre des arènes
quand j'étais jeune je pensais que dans
toutes les villes de France il y avait
une église des arènes un théâtre antique
que je me suis rendu compte un jour
qu'ils avaient ils avaient disparu de la
plupart des des villes mais j'étais très
marqué par cette
[Musique]
par cet héritage pour cet empreinte de
la de la romanité
on me demandait si j'étais catholiser
oui je suis
catholique et Romain
et
dans une famille très très modeste ma
mère était femme de ménage et
je n'avais pas de père voilà donc
fait mes études secondaires à Arles puis
je suis monté à Paris j'ai fait le
sciences pour
puis de l'économie de l'histoire aussi
voilà j'ai échoué à Léna
pas assez conforme
très bien
mon esprit un peu
rebelle
en tout cas
refuse se laisser enfermer dans un moule
n'a pas été suffisamment
suffisamment souple
j'ai un peu en colère dans le
au départ puis finalement je m'en suis
je m'en suis très bien remis j'avais
envie de servir l'État
particulièrement service militaire à
Saumur et puis ensuite
je suis rentré dans la banque et puis
il est hasard de la vie ont fait que
j'ai alternais un temps entre
secteur privé et puis le secteur public
à faire un peu de politique
je dois me définir c'est égoïste à l'âge
de 8 ans la première fois que j'ai vu
une famille dans les livres d'histoire
d'avant
que vous n'avez pas connu s'il y avait
des petites vignettes de photos en fait
à la main
en dessin puis il y avait un portrait du
général de Gaulle avec de sous écrit la
France a perdu une bataille mais la
France n'a pas perdu la guerre voilà je
suis devenu un gaulliste certes naïf
après ça c'est assez un peu étoffé mais
ça remonte aussi loin que ça dans mon
dans mon esprit et puis
[Musique]
m'intéressant à l'histoire je suis
devenu très vite aussi bonapartiste
et finalement ça va pas changer je suis
toujours Golo bonapartiste c'est le
premier livre que
il y avait pas de livre chez moi mais ma
grand-mère pour froid pour mes 11 ans
m'avait offert mon premier livre de qui
était vraiment à moi c'était
Napoléon d'Octave Aubry qui était un
très beau livre avec des des
reproductions de
à la fois de portraits de peinture de
l'Empire et voilà toute l'histoire de
toute l'histoire de l'épopée impériale
et voilà tout ça m'a tout ça m'a
fabriqué à peu près ce que je suis
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion de parler
plus à fond de anciens députés ensuite
ancien député
ancien ancienne pub de Sarkozy bon je
déteste ce mot alors
non mais plus je suis pas je suis pas un
écrivain public donc j'ai écrit voilà et
ma vie n'a pas commencé là mais ma vie
politique a commencé
en fait avec avec Philippe Séguin
et avec la cam on va dire que la
campagne de Maastricht ou
j'ai pris trois mois dans le privé à
l'époque et j'ai pris trois mois de
congés sabbatique pour faire cette
campagne qui a été la première et la
plus belle de ma vie c'est comme c'est
formidable les référendum surtout quand
ils ont de tels enjeux parce que vous
allez à la rencontre des gens mais vous
ne l'avez rien à leur demander pardonnez
pas vous avez pas les voir pour dire
voter pour moi je suis je suis le
meilleur je suis mieux dans vos y aller
pour pour leur part l'occurrence c'était
pour leur parler de la France pour leur
parler des des grands enjeux de ce de ce
traité pour leur parler de vouloir
parler d'économie de d'indépendance
nationale etc donc ça a été une
formidable
formidable campagne et là c'est terminé
sur le fil du rasoir par une par une
défaite et
c'est le moment où mon sens les choses
ont basculé pour notre pour notre pays
mais aussi pour aussi pour l'Europe
voilà ensuite
j'ai
participé enfin j'ai inspiré avant de
partir la campagne de Chirac sur la
fracture sociale
puis j'ai été commissaire au Plan à
l'époque où il existait encore un
commissariat au plan
voilà puis j'ai
fait un passage au trésor aussi dans la
vie j'étais
au cabinet de Charles Pasqua qui est
personnage que j'ai adoré
une dimension humaine
épaisseur humaine que seuls les gens
font de cette génération qui a 16 ans
était dans la Résistance et risquent
leur peau vous pouvez pouvez avoir voilà
donc
début de ma vie ma vie politique si je
puis dire mais j'en ai pas fait mon
[Musique]
passé ma profession avant avant de me
présenter un jour
une élection législative mais
mon parcours c'était voilà c'était
Charles Pasqua Philippe Séguin c'est moi
je suis rentré dans une famille
politique ou il y avait encore des
messes mer des chabands des
guichardes et debrées
à l'époque où Sciences Po plutôt que de
vénérer le wauquis selon on a du lait
des Michels Debré les gens qui avaient
fait la Constitution de la Cinquième
République qui avait qui avait rétabli
l'état bon les choses un peu un peu
changé depuis
voilà puis après je
après j'ai fait la campagne de Nicolas
Sarkozy la plupart des gens le savent
j'ai effectivement écrit avec lui
beaucoup de discours de la campagne de
2006-2007
ça a été un moment très
passionnant et c'est quelqu'un avec qui
était très très facile de travailler
autant c'est bien était un très
très grand monsieur quelqu'un qui avait
une dimension intellectuelle très très
grande et
mais qui était parfois qui avait parfois
un caractère un peu difficile on mange
quoi Sarkozy avait
un caractère beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
facile et c'est quelqu'un qui accepté de
la discussion la critique accepter de
bouger sur ces sur ces lignes donc pour
moi le discours c'était simplement le
moyen d'être
au coeur du dispositif et à l'endroit
stratégique pour là où se définissent
les les idées et les politiques voilà
donc c'est ce qui s'est c'est ce qui
s'est passé à la fois pendant la
campagne et puis ensuite pendant les 5
ans qui ont suivi que ce lui doit une
expérience
extraordinaire au coeur du au coeur du
pouvoir l'Élysée
voilà à l'époque de à la fois de la
crise géorgienne de la crise financière
de
très grand très très grand souvenir on a
moi j'étais très très intéressant par la
Méditerranée comme vous en doutez c'est
au moment des accords méditerranéen oui
c'est bon c'est témoigné en fait depuis
très longtemps
et on l'a partagé je veux dire avec
beaucoup d'intérêts et
d'essayer de quand j'étais commissaire
plan je m'étais dit un jour après tout
genre menais à penser ici dans ce
commissariat du plan qui n'allait pas
changer à l'époque de de d'endroit
et la pensée d'unité de l'Europe on
pourrait peut-être penser l'unité de la
Méditerranée
et ça avait été impossible de
faire avancer cette idée parce qu'elle
était
orthogonale avec avec la construction
européenne et donc personne ne voulait
s'engager sur sur cette voie et
Sarkozy est engagé donc on a construit
quelque chose qui a qui
RTA de très grandes difficultés
c'est-à-dire la fois au printemps arabe
à la crise financière mais mais
qui a été une
formidable expérience et je continue de
penser que
elle constitue en réalité une clé de
l'avenir et pour l'Europe et pour la
France et pour l'Afrique si on n'arrive
pas à faire que la Méditerranée ne soit
plus creusée de de haine
de rivalité de de
conflits de guerre de
[Musique]
gens qui se noie au milieu de la
Méditerranée parce que ils ont plus à
manger chez eux parce que il rêve d'une
Europe parfaitement totalement fantasmée
si on n'y arrive pas je pense que
[Musique]
on est parti pour des fins de grande
catastrophes dans nos rapports avec le
Moyen-Orient et avec l'Afrique on a trop
longtemps l'Europe a tourné le dos au
sud et
au fond son origine c'est le sud ça
civilisation elle est au sud sont son
berceau c'est la Méditerranée berceau de
sa civilisation c'est
et c'est un
géopoliticiens pivot stratégique
dans l'âge géopolitique du monde c'est à
l'époque on s'est beaucoup intéressé sur
les accords méditerranéens on a suivi
mon baraque
monté quelle réaction vous avez eu
quand la Libye a été déstabilisée par la
suite alors ça c'est ça vient plus tard
ça vient plus tard que la création de
l'Union de l'Union pour la Méditerranée
qui avait très bien commencé puisque on
avait même réussi à faire s'asseoir
table et Palestiniens et les Israéliens
alors que le palestin sont pas un état
l'autorité Palestine n'est pas reconnue
comme un état par
les
Israéliens et
la part à part la Libye qui n'allait pas
voulu participer tous les pays avaient
accepté de participer au grand
étonnement d'heures beaucoup de
diplomates de même que quand on avait
fait le sommet sur la Méditerranée
ça a été l'occasion pour
pour la Syrie de reconnaître pour la
première fois dans l'histoire la
souveraineté du Liban donc c'était des
acquis qui sont qui sont réalités
considérables qui a ensuite ce soir
circonstances de l'époque après la Libye
c'est une autre c'est une autre histoire
qu'on traite en général de façon un peu
caricaturale
la Libye c'est venu enfin l'intervention
en Libye elle est venue d'une visite des
des démocrates pour vous appeler comme
ça les démocrates libyens
qui sont venus nous expliquer que
faisait le tour de l'Europe que si on
intervenait pas
Kadhafi massacrée la population de
Benghazi il y avait à peu près un
million de un million de personnes
et on savait que c'était que c'était
vrai alors les experts géopolitiques
aujourd'hui ont beau dire pas vrai ça ne
serait jamais arrivé tous les
renseignements qu'on avait montré que
c'était une éventualité assez probable
et
assez probable c'est probable jamais
être absolument certain il avait
concentré
il avait juré de les il avait juré de
détruire la ville et on a vu toutes les
bonnes raisons de penser que il le
ferait voilà
et
dans ce cas le président de la
République vous savez il est seul devant
sa conscience lui dit si vous nous aidez
pas il va tuer un million de personnes
encore une fois les renseignements qu'on
a montrent que c'est pas une du
renseignement français ou du
renseignement
français se nourrit aussi de il se
nourrit aussi de renseignement voilà
donc c'était voilà c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle on a on a été suivi par
d'autres en particulier les en
particulier les Anglais
donc moi j'ai vu un président de la
République seul devant sa conscience
mais personne ne peut
en tout cas pas moi aujourd'hui mettre
un jugement sur
ce qu'il ferait lui-même
face à un tel cas de conscience moi je
crois qu'en politique comme d'ailleurs
dans la vie la morale n'est pas dans la
bonne conscience mais dans le cas de
conscience c'est-à-dire dans ce moment
on peut déchirant dans lequel on est
obligé de on est fait tout seul face à
ça
à sa conscience ça déchirure de sa
conscience entre
des solutions qui ont toutes des
inconvénients mais entre lesquels vous
êtes obligés de choisir donc vous pouvez
pas Luder votre responsabilité donc il a
il a il a il a fait ce choix de
l'intervention
personne n'avait l'intention de faire la
guerre moi je considérais que on avait
une question qu'on se posait pas mais
qu'on se pose toujours pas aujourd'hui
avec l'Ukraine par exemple c'est c'est
pas parce que on n'a pas l'intention de
faire la guerre que on se trouve pas
entraîné dans la guerre voilà je pense
que quand on commence à bombarder des
colonnes de de char
on n'est pas sûr que même si on a décidé
de s'en tenir là qu'on va s'en tenir là
on a fait le mandat de l'ONU pour faire
ça oui bien sûr
le mandat de l'ONU absolument les Russes
ne s'y sont pas opposés donc c'est une
opération du point de vue la légalité
internationale mais qui pour moi n'est
pas la chose la plus importante
à son occasion d'en reparler en
parlant un peu plus de géopolitique
l'alimenta de l'ONU sont pas des
Américains qui nous ont entraînés
c'est une opération qui a été
conduite par les Anglais et les Français
qui ont entraîné les Européens
et qui ont entraîné l'OTAN ensuite parce
que on a aussi besoin de ça de sa
logistique voilà et qui s'est faite avec
avec le soutien de
beaucoup de pays du Golfe
voilà mais il y avait deux inconvénients
c'était un de se laisser entraîner dans
la dans la guerre personne n'avait
personne n'y est allé pour changer le
régime par exemple mais
l'engrenage le espèce de montée aux
extrêmes qui est toujours là qui est la
caractéristique de la guerre
a fini par entraîner tout le monde dans
cette
cette tragédie qui a fini par quel on a
le régime s'est effondré et puis le
deuxième le deuxième danger là aussi sur
lequel je trouve qu'il y avait ma
réflexion était peut-être pas suffisante
c'est que
tout le monde savait que c'était un pays
tribal
là donc une fois que le régime est tombé
mais encore une fois personne voulait
leur renverser
les tribus elles sont je peux le couper
sans revenir à la surface je peux vous
couper oui bien sûr
on a fourni les renseignements pour que
Kadhafi se fasse attraper
on a dit voilà le téléphone il se trouve
dans tel 4K donc il doit être
potentiellement là
et ce qu'il fallait le laisser se faire
pendre ou est-ce qu'il fallait l'emmener
devant un tribunal international
je crois que personne n'a eu le temps de
se poser cette
ceux qui ont fourni l'enseignement moi
cette question enfin moi je n'ai pas
souvenir du tout que cette question ce
soir ce soit posé
[Musique]
il a il a essayé de se cacher de partir
et puis c'est fait
il s'est fait rattraper en tout cas
ni la France ni l'Angleterre donc
commandité le l'assassinat de Kadhafi
pour ce qu'il faut sortir des grands
complots
est arrivé ce qui est arrivé ce qui est
arrivé à bien d'autres c'est
un régime qui est tout fait un certain
nombre de forces va tout des forces
démocratiques bien sûr et il y avait
sans doute aussi il y avait beaucoup de
gens qui voulaient qui voulaient
l'éliminer
peut-être de pays aussi mais on n'a pas
trempé un instant dans cette dans cette
histoire les choses se sont faites
encore une fois dans l'engrenage de la
violence et et de la décomposition
complète de l'État libyen
vous faisiez un parallèle avec l'Ukraine
l'escalade de la guerre l'engrenage de
la guerre quand on commence à mettre le
doigt dedans fait souvent
mes derniers c'est c'est il m'a pas valu
que des amis qui vous détracteurs à ce
moment-là comment quelles étaient vos
détracteurs au moment de la tribu tous
ceux qui sont tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont atteints du syndrome de Munich pour
qui
si vous ne
si vous expliquez que on risque
d'engrenage que la guerre c'est un
engrenage c'est une montée aux extrêmes
dont on ne sait pas à l'avance si on ne
va pas en perdre très vite la maîtrise
tout cela tout ce qui était pour la
guerre en Irak tous ceux qui étaient
pour
en Libye la guerre en Libye la guerre en
Syrie la guerre partout ceux qui pensent
toujours que
il faut
faire organiser des croisades contre le
monde entier
qui ne pense pas comme nous qui
qui voit munique partout c'est donc si
vous êtes contre la guerre en Irak vous
êtes pour Hitler si vous êtes si vous
êtes pour pour qu'on évite la guerre en
Ukraine et on a rien fait pour l'éviter
et on n'a rien fait après pour l'arrêter
on continue à ne rien faire pour
l'arrêter bon mais si vous êtes sur
cette position là
vous êtes pour Hitler c'est pas
compliqué c'est un peu la rhétorique de
George Bush non si vous êtes avec nous
vous êtes contre nous danser soit vous
êtes contre soit vous êtes avec nous
soit vous êtes compris
de d'un État qui est qui est un état
dominant vous êtes avec mon contre moi
derrière il y a autre chose il y a il y
a ce procès en procès moral qui est fait
à tous ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
pour faire la guerre chaque fois que
l'occasion se présente enfin c'est c'est
voilà et qui voit Hitler partout
ce qui d'ailleurs
a finalement
ça finit à force de voir partout Hitler
et des crimes contre l'humanité
finit par annuler la singularité de la
joie
c'est
mais c'est
pas bien enfin il y a
des philosophes des journalistes des
gens enfin
d'une violence
hallucinante c'est les comprendre il
faut aussi les comprendre mais je
comprends les Ukrainiens en revanche je
comprends pas la violence
les gens qui me disent mais tous les
gens qui pensent pas comme moi sont des
traîtres il faut aller fusiller si vous
voulez voilà non je cherche pas à les
comprendre ça m'intéresse pas de les
comprendre
tous les gens qui vous expliquent que si
vous êtes pour un Cécile font en Ukraine
vous êtes Marcel desa c'est-à-dire en
collabo c'est-à-dire un [__]
non ça m'intéresse pas de les comprendre
mais c'est une vieille histoire histoire
de vie du syndrome de Munich
on en parle déjà avec la guerre de Corée
puis avec la guerre du Vietnam alors
chaque fois c'est le Munich asiatique
après c'est après on parle de ça pour
pour l'Irak
c'est toujours enfin on parle de ça pour
la Syrie que n'a-t-on entendu sur Obama
quand il a refusé d'intervenir en Syrie
ah mais
un des gens qui
une chose pour la France qui refusé
le le conflit irakien oui bien sûr non
mais faut voir ce que ce que
la pression que cet exercice sur Jacques
Chirac quand il a refusé d'aller en Irak
faut dire qu'on avait des services de
renseignement qui nous avait un petit
peu
Baqué notre président avec du bon
renseignement
bref
ça a été le mensonge américain bon mais
indépendamment même du mensonge
américain c'est-à-dire
moi j'ai trouvé ça extraordinaire les
mêmes aujourd'hui d'ailleurs qui
explique que il faut il faut abattre le
faut abattre la Russie expliquer toute
une Russie maintenant on en est plus à
Poutine il a commencé à avoir plein de
gens beaucoup de gens qui vous disent
voilà qui ont repris la thèse de l'accue
valaisart vous savez c'est au fond il
faut en finir avec la Russie alors c'est
la thèse des Polonais mais pas seulement
vous pouvez commencer à trouver sur les
plateaux de télévision des gens que je
trouve que finalement
voilà mais ces gens là qui prêchent vers
une anniation de la Russie
[Musique]
le même coup avec l'Irak avec l'Irak
c'était même mot les mêmes mots c'est un
dictateur sanglant oui
il ment tout le temps et si on arrête
pas là on arrêtera plus
bon les mêmes mots alors c'est bien
après ils ont été ravis on a abattu le
dictateur
le régime on l'a tué
ça entraînait sans doute directement
indirectement plus d'un million de morts
la naissance de daesh
des millions de réfugiés
la guerre en Syrie
bon je pense que le bilan est enfin
si la morale c'est dans la c'est de
créer ce genre de conséquence alors je
pense qu'on n'a pas la même conception
de la de la morale e et moi et moi je
suis pas le seul enfin je veux dire je
après tout je préfère être dans le même
camp que que à bermace que Edgar Morin
que Christine gere que dans le leur
voilà franchement je
est-ce que ce qu'on a le droit de
s'interroger sur les conséquences de ce
qu'on fait voilà est-ce que on a est-ce
qu'il est tellement admirable à la fois
intellectuellement et moralement
d'expulser la dimension tragique de
l'histoire de la de notre vie
de nos décisions moi j'avais cité dans
ma dans ma tribu dans ma tribune une un
texte que je trouve extrêmement
comment dire
OK
très emblématique de ce qu'est la
confrontation avec un dilemme tragique
c'est un texte de René Char
d'aix-en-prose mais
qui raconte un épisode de de la
résistance parce que René charpendant la
résistance était chef de maquis
et il raconte quand même atteint il se
trouve
sur les hauteurs d'un village avec ces
maquisards
ils sont armés
peuvent tuer tous les gens qui sont qui
sont dans le village et dans le village
il y a des Allemands qui viennent
arrêter de leur copains
qui étaient caché là et il a été dénoncé
les Allemands viennent de chercher
et donc il dit tous les regards
me demandent autour de moi me demande
d'intervenir
tous les regards me demandent de tuer
les Allemands puisqu'on peut les tuer
savent pas qu'on est là et ils sont
vraiment dans notre ligne de
et ils disent je n'ai pas donné cet
ordre
mais il dit avec un déchirement toute
enfin tout à la
c'est une horrible journée c'est un
horrible moment il dit je n'ai pas donné
pourquoi parce que si l'on avait tué des
Allemands
des Allemands seraient revenus et ils
auraient tué tout le village
donc je n'ai pas donné leur ça c'est un
dilemme tragique c'est à dire que peut
se dire après tout ce qu'on se dit
souvent on entend souvent aujourd'hui
c'est après tout
moi je suis pas responsable moi je tue
les Allemands c'est des [__]
je sauve mon copains
sauvé c'est tout ça après ils vont
massacrer village c'est pas moi
sans les Allemands
sont responsables d'abord si c'était pas
venus nous envahir ça arrivera et puis
c'est eux qui sont les auteurs du
massacre comme si celui qui va décider à
cet instant là
de tuer ou non les Allemands n'avaient
aucune part de responsabilité à cet
instant dans ce qui allait suivre
ben non il a une part de responsabilité
dans ce qui va suivre cet instant il
doit prendre une décision et la décision
c'est de sauver l'un et de condamner les
autres ou de sauver les autres et de
condamner là et cette responsabilité là
vous ne pouvez pas vous en débarrasser
enfin en tout cas la morale c'est que
et s'en débarrasser c'est pas à la
morale c'est le contraire de la morale
voilà c'est à dire le cas de conscience
devant ce dilemme tragique c'est ça la
morale et c'est ça en particulier la
morale en politique c'est ça en
particulier la morale du commandement la
morale du chef
et pas la bonne conscience pas vous
savez c'est moi j'ai dit il y a quelques
jours ce ne sont pas le temps du bien
d'ailleurs il faut regarder comment nous
en sommes arrivés dans par exemple avec
l'Ukraine à la situation actuelle nous
avons aussi une part de responsabilités
et nous seul fait de s'interroger sur
notre part de responsabilité ne dédouane
pas plus les Russes de ce qu'ils font ou
de ce qu'ils ont fait que la décision de
René-Charles dédouanée les allemandes de
ce qu'il faisait mais
elle nous conduit à considérer que nous
ne sommes pas le camp du Bien nous avons
aussi notre part de responsabilité si
nous sommes le camp du Bien c'est très
dangereux de penser penser que vous êtes
le bien
mais le bien il peut tout se permettre
tout
dans ma tribune je suis très souvent
je conduis bien mais
il m'a dit mais certains m'ont dit mais
pendant la guerre voilà
absolu il parle mais ce que ça veut dire
que nous étions du Bien absolu
mais
et les bombardements des villes
allemandes
des populations civiles
allemandes les dizaines de milliers de
morts brûlés vif par les bons
incendiaires délibérément
peut-être que c'était une nécessité de
la guerre mais vous appelez ça le bien
dommage que la terre les Allemands vous
faites avec Staline je comprends très
bien mais vous pouvez pas dire je suis
le camp de bien je suis bien
de l'armoire récemment mais ça prouve
quand même que parfois il y a dans le
bien il y a le mal aussi
c'était mais sinon vous pouvez tout vous
permettre
et ça c'est la pire des choses voilà
c'est non nous ne sommes pas le camp du
Bien
si les deux s'il est deux des deux côtés
les adversaires par chacun qui sont les
qui sont le bien alors vous allez vers
la ça fait la guerre la plus absolue qui
soit
mais bon c'est
des croisades c'est
vous tuer tout le monde puisque après
tout vous allez la vérité
vous savez le pays de la pire des choses
dans l'histoire humaine ce sont les
absolus
c'est à dire c'est après tout je suis la
vérité je suis le bien
je peux tout bien il y a pas de limite
voilà moi je suis
dans mon panthéon il y a il y a entre
autres Camus alors je sais que les
imbéciles considèrent que c'était un
philosophe pour que la terminale
je pense qu'il mérite mieux que ça
et il dit enfin c'est un défiléatoires
de son de son œuvre conducteur de son
œuvre c'est dit nous avons besoin d'une
philosophie des limites
la question morale c'est celle là la
question morale c'est sommes-nous
capables de nous mettre des limites et
de penser que même si nous croyons avoir
la vérité qu'elle soit religieuse
scientifique ou autre même si nous
pensons que finalement nous sommes mieux
que que ceux d'en face est-ce que nous
sommes capables
mettre une limite à ce que nous pouvons
déduire de cette de cette croyance de
cette foi dans cette forme même en nous
immense qualité à nos émotions
la vraie question il faut
Camus dans Caligula dans le début de
Caligula
des cris cette scène que je trouve très
en fait très très
intéressant très qui nous apprend
beaucoup de choses au fond si on veut
bien y réfléchir deux minutes
c'est au début
voire Caligula qui est désespéré triste
ils viennent perdre sa sœur
alors on sait pas trop si
il avait des
sentiments ou des relations avec sa sœur
plus
profond que les relations entre frères
et sœurs mais en tout cas il est
désespéré
arrive à ses conseillers
dit César je
fais quelque chose à te dire je dis non
moi ma sœur est morte
d'autres choses à faire
c'est pas le moment César c'est très
important non non mais c'est pas le
moment non mais César c'est la chose la
plus importante au monde
bon alors si tu veux me parler de quoi
du Trésor c'est ça
il faut de l'argent
bon écoutez j'ai une idée
on va demander on va obliger chaque
citoyen de l'Empire à faire un testament
en faveur de l'État
et puis après chaque année on en tuera
un certain nombre sort on les exécutera
et comme ça
conseiller un peu effaré
on a bien dit que c'était la chose la
plus importante au monde
donc c'est la chose la plus importante
au monde c'est plus important que tant
que la vie humaine c'est plus important
que tout et il dit quelque chose du
genre mais
partir de maintenant nous allons vivre
selon la logique d'aller voir vous allez
souffrir
la logique
de la logique
magnifique la logique qui pourrait ne
pas vouloir la logique
pousser donc la logique jusqu'au bout
et vous avez la scène de la première
scène de la
caducalibula de Camus
pour vous quelles sont les racines du
conflit Rousseau
ukrainien
très profonde des racines alors il y a
les racines immédiates il y a les
racines les moins profondes qui sont
qui vont qui remontent à
la fin de nos soviétique mais en 91
encore une fois ce que j'ai dit
pas le problème essayons de comprendre
moi j'entends des gens qui disent mais
non pas vrai on a tout fait pour on a
tout fait pour garder la Russie dans le
pour la rassurer pour la société 91
l'Occident a le choix du l'Occident
c'était surtout les États-Unis mais
c'est dans le choix l'Occident le centre
soutenir Gorbatchev vous soutenir la
team
on a pleuré sur Gorbatchov il y a
quelques mois quand il est mort un peu
quand même c'était bon mais on a lâché
parce qu'on est ce que vous ce qu'on
voulait
ce qu'on avait gagné la guerre froide
c'était affaiblir le plus possible
la Russie
donc elle signe c'était très bien c'est
pour ça que Macron dit il faut pas
humilier la Russie
non je crois que ça c'est autre chose
mais
à ce moment-là on a choisi délibérément
la solution qui démonte les
pas seulement l'Union soviétique en
réalité l'Empire russe voilà c'est pas
Lyon soviétique il y a inventé l'Ukraine
russe qui a inventé la biodorucyrus qui
a inventé les pays baltaurus voilà c'est
c'est
l'héritage de l'empire des arts c'est
pas vous savez la l'Ukraine elle est
pourquoi elle est pourquoi elle est
devenue russe l'Ukraine a été occupé par
les Polonais
et un jour les cosaques du Nieppe sont
allés chercher le tsar pour qu'il ait
débarrasse des Polonais
parce que le Zara accepté ils ont fini
les Russes ont fini par repousser les
par repousser les Polonais et
petit à petit la légende s'est
transformée en
on va dire en soumission voilà le crâne
est devenu l'Ukraine qui était quand
même rappelé aussi le berceau de la le
berceau de la de la Russie c'est la
Russie elle n'est à Kiev
à Moscou c'est un rameau après de
la de la réussite Kiev bon mais
ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant c'est avant même de remonter
aussi loin c'est la cette période qui
commence en 91 où on est très satisfait
de voir de devoir démonteler la voir
démanteler la soviétique
on soutien on va le soutenir pendant des
années
à bout de bras
malgré la corruption malgré imaginer
et puis ensuite
que fait-on ensuite on étend comment ça
étendre l'OTAN
alors on dit pareil que certains disent
que des États-Unis avaient promis que
tendrai pas l'OTAN
d'autres dit c'est pas vrai il y a pas
d'écrit mais enfin on est quand même de
fortes présomption pour que la promesse
était faite mais indépendamment de ça
c'est très intéressant les plus grands
spécialistes de géopolitiques américains
ont écrit pendant des années qui tendent
l'OTAN jusqu'au frontières de la Russie
c'était prendre un risque considérable
je rappelle quand même que le temps il
avait été fait pour pour
qui bref
de Varsovie c'est une alliance défensive
et pas de Varsovie il avait disparu donc
cette volonté d'étendre progressivement
longtemps jusqu'au frontières de la
Russie tout le monde savait tout le
monde savait que c'était prendre un
risque considérable et que la Russie ne
pouvait pas ne pas l'interpréter comme
une forme d'agression une menace
en 2008
l'actuel patron de la CIA s'appelle
Arthur Benz parti pardon
moi j'oubliais son prénom
est ambassadeur de des États-Unis à
Moscou
et il écrit une note à condoles on est
en 2008 c'est à dire l'année de la
l'année de la Géorgie et la crise
financière et la crise financière et de
la question c'est pas beaucoup jouer sur
la cette question là et il écrit que
faire rentrer l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN ce
serait
considéré comme casus Belly je vous
coupe
à quelqu'un sur internet de notre
communauté fact checking urgent le pack
de Varsovie est postérieur au Traité de
l'Atlantique vrai ou faux
je me souviens pas enfin en tout cas
c'était les deux frères jumeaux je sais
c'est possible
mais là
c'était quand même le Traité de
l'Atlantique Nord il a été il a été créé
contre le l'Union soviétique parce que
on peut discuter du pack de Varsovie je
rappelle quand même que tous les pays
qui se sont rentrés dans le pack de
Varsovie étaient des pays qui étaient
dès 1944 45
occupé par les Soviétiques les
transformer tous en dans lequel on a
soviétique avait implanté des régimes
communistes voilà donc après je sais
plus à une année près que deux ans près
qu'elle a été le le
moment où on a signé le Pacte de
Varsovie et le Traité de l'Atlantique de
l'Atlantique Nord mais
les deux enfin voilà c'est pas
absolument incontestable que les deux
les frères jumeaux par jumeaux ennemis
depuis le début on a fait le pacte on a
fait le temps contre le danger
soviétique c'est contre le bloc
soviétique et le bloc soviétique
il est là dès dès 1945
je rappelle qu'il y a le temps
c'est bien avant 1945 et
occidentaux d'accepter en 1949 Varsovie
des dates mais donc soviétique il est là
avant le pack de Varsovie donc de
lizaraz donc il écrit en 2008 il y a
quand je les arrache une note en disant
moi j'ai vu
je suis plus deux ans j'ai vu tout le
monde les partisans du régime les
opposants il y a personne en Russie qui
considère que que l'OTAN
Ukrain d'entrée du crâne dans le temps
ne serait pas une menace et donc il dit
il prévoit d'ailleurs très de façon très
très ça c'est 2008 c'est 2008 2008
qu'elle a amené des qui est une année de
crise par ce monde que financière mais
qui est une année de laquelle il y a la
il va y avoir la Géorgie à la Géorgie
il y a la Révolution
en Ukraine il y a
et il y a la candidature surtout du
crâne et de la Géorgie à l'OTAN
et différentes traits c'est prendre un
gros risque
vous verrez les Russes d'abord se
prendre des réussissent sur la sur la
Crimée
ils avanceront dans le bombasse ce qu'il
dit en quelques en quelques lignes et
vraiment ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé
quelques années à quelques années après
bon
et celui qui écrit ça c'est encore une
fois c'est pas
c'est pas
un adversaire des des démocrates
[Musique]
américains qui sont les héritiers du de
la des croisades ulssonienne c'est donc
il a
il y a une vision très très claire donc
tout le monde sait je veux dire tout le
monde l'a dit tout le monde a vu les
dangers
même même brésinsky quand un peu avant
sa mort qui pourtant était toujours été
pour affaiblir la Russie il y a toujours
été parti en affaiblir la Russie
dit en 2014 et encore en 2015
c'est-à-dire en 2015 après même après
l'annexion de la de la Crimée quand même
la meilleure solution ça serait ça
serait une solution à la Finlandaise
pour pour l'Ukraine
il faut comme disait Kissinger
l'Ukraine ne sera jamais pour les Russes
un pays comme les autres l'Occident doit
le comprendre et donc l'Ukraine doit
rester un pont entre les deux mondes et
vouloir l'attirer dans l'un ou dans
l'autre
finira mal
c'est donc personne n'est enfin pas dire
qu'on a découvert le risque quand
Poutine en
Ukraine ça n'est pas vrai donc tout le
monde a fait ça de façon délibérée
une fois chacun
considérant l'autre comme une comme une
menace
on a eu
déroulé classique de la montée vers la
guerre
moi j'avais pris l'exemple de la guerre
de 14 non pas par analogie mais juste
parce que l'histoire elle nous apprend
au fond beaucoup sur ce que nous sommes
nous les humains c'est c'est
ça se passe toujours à peu près il y a
une chose qui se passe toujours à peu
près de la même façon c'est les mêmes
mécanismes psychologiques politiques
qui sont à l'oeuvre
on a fait exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire les Allemands ils se sont
trouvés
quand le pacte enfin quand l'Alliance
franco-rus a été signé ils ont eu
l'impression d'être encercler bon et ils
ont ils ont vécu dans l'obsession de cet
encerclement et d'être attaqué sur deux
fronts
tout le monde a personne ne voulait la
guerre en 1914
personne
personne n'a aucun chef d'État n'était
fou et dire c'est juste la faute du
Kaiser du militarisme allemand n'est pas
suffisant même si les Allemands sont
responsables d'avoir déclenché la guerre
seulement voilà le
la France avait dit à la Russie façon
quoi que vous fassiez on sera à vos
côtés
quand la Russie a fait une mobilisation
partielle il y a déjà eu chez les
Allemands une
sentiment d'être menacé ou assiégé mais
quand elle est passée d'un coup à la
mobilisation complète des Allemands ont
immédiatement déclaré la guerre parce
que s'attendait être attaqué
et nous avions dit aux Russes encore une
fois nous avions au fond poussé les
Russes à l'imprudence en disant quoi
qu'il arrive toute façon on sera là ce
qui s'est passé d'ailleurs aussi en
Ukraine quand vous regardez le
partenariat stratégique signé en
novembre 2021 avec les entre les
Américains et l'Ukraine la Russie est
désignée comme l'ennemi
le la promesse d'entrée d'entrer dans
l'OTAN est écritoire sur blanc
car vous le lisez ça veut dire de toute
façon on sera là ne vous inquiétez pas
vous pouvez
aucune retenue et ça ça n'était que la
transcription écrite de de tout ce qui
se faisait depuis au moins depuis 2014
les Américains ont du Vespa vous les
accords de bien ce que vous voulez vous
les appliquez pas mais c'est pas grave
au contraire c'est très bien enfin voilà
vous pouvez faire on sera là donc toute
façon
l'été évident que
les Russes de leur côté parce qu'ils
pour des raisons enfin ils sentaient
menacer à trois raisons c'est pas le
sujet et les Ukrainiens parce qu'ils se
sentaient menacés par les Russes
et les Américains une partie des
Européens parce que
pour les pays de l'Est santé menacés par
la Russie pour les Américains
au fond vers la Russie c'était quand
même une c'est un objectif
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus important
qu'on ne l'a dit
ce qu'on a souvent dit oui mais
l'Américain c'est pas leur c'est pas
leur préoccupation principale enfin
et d'ailleurs en 2008 mon burn s'écrit
sa note
deux je passe deux événements importants
le premier c'est la Géorgie parce que la
Géorgie va rentrer dans l'OTAN veut
passer du temps occidental donc la
Russie envahit la Géorgie il y a de
République c'est un peu la même histoire
que le non-basse et l'ougance
qui qui sont en Sécession l'armée
géorgienne
se déploie pour combattre les
sécessionnistes et les Russes viennent à
ce cours des sécessionnistes et si
Nicolas Sarkozy était pas allé négocier
avec les Russes et les Géorgiens
aujourd'hui ce serait une république
République russe de plus voilà
ils avancées ils avancées très très vite
et
georgènes à l'époque était pas capable
de résister très très longtemps et avant
ça c'était passé
l'épisode de l'OTAN
pousse à l'entrée de les pays de l'Est à
l'entrée des à l'entrée de la Géorgie et
de l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN c'est la France
et l'Allemagne qui s'y sont opposés
alors maintenant on explique en fait
c'est pas bien de s'y opposé la preuve
Si j'étais rentrée à l'époque
aujourd'hui on n'aurait pas rentrer en
préparé en Ukraine on peut se dire aussi
que si à l'époque ils étaient on avait
accepté ce qui serait d'abord il serait
pas rentré la procédure d'adhésion
aurait commencé bon on a eu la guerre
plutôt
voilà si on peut se dire ça aussi et et
avec une
Ukraine qui était beaucoup moins
préparée beaucoup moins armée encore
qu'elle ne l'était au début de l'année
dernière
mais voilà tout ça tout ça c'est fait je
veux dire tout le monde à sa part de
responsabilité dans cette affaire et au
fond tout le monde savait très bien ce
qu'il faisait ça avait très bien qu'elle
risque qu'il prenait où il faisait
prendre il faisait prendre la paix c'est
donc là le fait de
d'être surpris c'est
pas vrai c'est non mais il y a des gens
qui sont surpris sur les plateaux télé
on a tout entendu
puisque derrière souvent les gens qu'on
interroge ont des gens qui ont
[Musique]
qui ont travaillé pour l'OTAN qui
travaille pour l'Union européenne qui
ont des intérêts enfin il y a beaucoup
de gens qui qui sont
que ça soit des experts militaires ou
des géopoliticiens quand même beaucoup
de gens qui n'ont pas intérêt à déplaire
à leurs clients donc voilà mais puis
après il y a ceux qui ont qui défendent
toujours les mêmes idées depuis très
longtemps qui est défendaient sur la sur
la Serbie sur les races sur la Syrie
c'est pas il y a pas là non plus il y a
pas de surprises c'est
la réponse à la propagande de guerre des
deux camps mais forcément
l'esprit
français là-dedans il devient quoi je
sais pas pendant l'esprit français
devient quoi là-dedans l'esprit de on va
pas en guerre en Irak l'esprit de tout
ça il en est où c'est pas on va pas la
garniracle faisait pas la guerre les
rats faisaient à ce moment-là les
raccour faisaient la guerre à personne
et quand il y a eu la première guerre du
Golfe à la guerre du Golfe parce que
l'Irak avait envahi le Koweït le père
bouche fait un bouche paire qui était
Président des États-Unis il a eu la
sagesse d'arrêter là la coalition
internationale à la frontière de l'Irak
il aurait pu rentrer on va pas on va pas
rentrer on va pas on va pas renverser le
régime d'ailleurs c'est renversement de
régime c'est pas par l'Occident et les
occupations de l'Occident finissent
toujours la même façon c'est-à-dire très
mal voilà bon
son fils a pas eu la même n'a pas eu la
même retenue la
France moi je me souviens de la France a
particularité c'est d'abord d'avoir une
voix singulière la sienne
de ne pas vouloir se laisser entraîner
dans une guerre qu'elle n'aurait pas
voulu c'est à dire comment ce que dit De
Gaulle en 66 quand on quand on sort des
organes militaires intégrés de l'OTAN
sur pas de l'Alliance atlantique
on n'est jamais sorti de l'OTAN ça m'est
sorti de l'Atlantique
traitée de l'Atlantique non on est sorti
des organes militaires intégrés c'est
pas la même chose dans ce contexte qui
était radicalement différent qui était
un contexte dans lequel il y avait des
bases américaines en France
dans lequel les Américains contre les
complètement complètement l'OTAN
et d'un contexte de guerre froide
général de Gaulle n'a jamais renié
l'alliance défensive entre les pays
occidentaux face
aux pattes de Varsovie soviétique
mais il a dit
deux choses qui sont importantes tu dis
la France ne veut pas se laisser
entraîner dans une guerre qui ne serait
pas la sienne elle sera aux côtés de ses
alliés
s'il y a une agression à condition
évidemment de pas être battre soi-même
responsable de l'agression c'est voilà
donc c'est et il a tenu parole chaque
fois qu'il y a eu une crise entre avant
et après entre les stylouest
mais c'est pour ça qu'il était respecté
de des Russes
parce que
quelqu'un qui connaissait la
géopolitique connaissait l'histoire
en plus la Russie de Staline avait été
le premier état si mes souvenirs sont
exacts à reconnaître la France libre et
le premier voyage que fait le général à
la Libération c'est en Russie
mais parce que c'était à ses yeux aussi
c'est d'abord c'est un facteur
d'équilibre dans le monde
et puis l'alliance franco-us
elle est ancienne alors il y a eu des
moments où elle
se transformer en guerre comme on comme
la guerre de Crimée ou ou
la campagne de Russie mais
je crois que l'idée
c'était que la Russie elle était elle
comptait elle pesait énormément qu'on le
veuille ou non elle faisait partie du
monde européen
l'Europe de l'Atlantique à l'oral depuis
Pierre Legrand en tout cas la Russie
avait
une tropisme européen très important
si on remonte très loin
ceux qu'on a appelé la Russie a toujours
eu un lien avec l'Occident alors ça a
été l'Occident l'orient de l'occident
quand les liens quand on développer les
liens avec ils ont développé leur
premier lien avec Byzance
mais il y a toujours eu une implication
qu'elle soit économique politique
ou autre de la Russie
avec avec l'Europe la civilisation russe
est une branche de la civilisation
européenne
la Russie se convertit au christianisme
et elle a une elle se veut à trois
raisons mais tout ça ça compte dans
l'imaginaire des peuples après la chute
de Byzance elle s'est voulu le
successeur de Byzance Moscou c'était la
troisième Rome
voilà celle qui était à la tête de de
à la fois de la religion et de la
civilisation orthodoxe qui était plus
plus simple à ses yeux plus purs que que
la religion catholique mais c'était le
roi historique de de la Russie des
empires ont toujours cette forme de rôle
historique on remet l'historique à
conquérir à diriger le monde vocation à
diriger le monde
nous sommes Empire romain germanique
avait aussi une vocation universelle
facile c'est le propre des empires
d'ailleurs quelque chose qu'on qu'on
oublie dans ce dans ce dans le débat
actuel
ce sont ces choses profondes qui ne
concernent pas que la Russie qui est qui
sont notamment la l'éternel de
compétition concurrence voir lutte entre
les empires et les nations
mais
sont une des formes les plus anciennes
de l'organisation des peuples c'est pas
c'est pas propre là c'est pas propre à
la Russie et nous vivons bien nous sur
cette toujours sur cette nostalgie
de l'Empire romain de la comme une
partie de la de l'Europe centrale vit
sur la nostalgie de l'empire des réseaux
c'est
voilà c'est c'est dans certaines régions
du monde
où les peuples sont très imbriqués
qu'on Empire se retire
il laisse des débris partout c'est à
dire que voilà on a quand on a démoli
l'Empire au seront roi en 1919
on a laissé des des problèmes
pendant toute l'Europe centrale ça qui
n'ont pas
peu contribué à ensuite
au conflit suivant et on a supprimé un
facteur d'É quilibre entre l'Allemagne
et puis
l'Empire l'Empire au son donc
mais on oublie que ce sont deux formes
de forme concurrentes les nations et les
et les empires
l'histoire de la France en Europe c'est
c'est toujours l'opposition à l'Empire
en fait voilà c'est la c'est la fameuse
phrase du roi de France et le roi de
France et on pourra dans son royaume
la France a toujours refusé
une fois l'empire de Charlemagne
enfin ses défait toujours refusé de de
se rallier à l'Empire c'est l'empire
l'empereur était normalement le le
supérieur de tous les souverains
d'Europe
[Musique]
la Russie moi Pierre Legrand elle
devient européenne il impose le costume
européen les mars européennes
on invite les philosophes des
philosophes européens sous Catherine II
on a le
Voltaire on parle français d'ailleurs on
parle français mais ça on parle français
dans toute la y compris en Russie après
les guerres après les guerres de
l'Empire elle est elle est une des
pièces maîtresses du système qui naît de
des du Congrès de Vienne
que ce que
jusqu'aux années
1848 même
bon donc elle est impliquée directement
dans le dans la vie dans la vie
européenne
mais c'est l'époque
début du 19e siècle ou né en Russie un
mouvement qui va appeler le
slavophilisme mouvement cela vous filme
qui revendique de ne plus être
simplement une imitateur de de
l'Occident et des Européens alors ça n'a
pose beaucoup de problèmes ils ont
reconstruit aussi et on construit un
imaginaire russe parfois de toutes
pièces ils ont reconstruit une histoire
mais ils ont aussi engendré la
littérature et la grande littérature
russe
voilà tolsoï est un des premiers
slavophile en réalité bon et toute la
grande littérature russe va
sortir de ce mouvement de cette
sensibilité stavoine
il y a le besoin pour une partie en tout
cas de l'élite de l'élitrus
de cultiver une singularité russe dans
la culture dans les arts dans la pensée
dans la politique
cette spécificité elle était de toute
façon ancrée dans ancré dans son dans
son histoire parce qu'un pays aussi
gigantesque aussi divers avec un tel
mélange de superposition de peuples de
culture de religion
pendant en fait pendant que j'étais
pendant que j'étais à l'Élysée mais
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir passé 10 ans
aux États-Unis non plus pour pour savoir
ce que les États sont les États-Unis
pas besoin de passer 10 ans en Russie
pour savoir ce qu'il a réussi quand
c'est on peut apprendre on peut
apprendre d'autres membres voilà c'est
même souvent les gens qui vivent
on étudie enfin n'étudie pas le monde
dans lequel ils vivent c'est
pas je sais pas un critère de de c'est
pas un critère de connaissance ou de de
ce qui était là et je pense que le
général de Gaulle aille mieux compris ce
qui était la Russie par exemple et alors
qu'il y a jamais vécu qu'il n'y est allé
qu'en voyage officiel que
beaucoup de experts qui s'expriment sur
les plateaux quand vous étiez là-bas
dans le cadre de l'Élysée
vous avez mis des petites fleurs à la
statue du général de Gaulle à Moscou des
choses comme ça
nous sommes pas si on a fait des on a
mis des petites fleurs
il me semble pas non
vous avez pas vu la statue du général de
Gaulle à Moscou
du général de Gaulle à Moscou on est
allé au Kremlin ça oui
soin pas d'une cérémonie particulière
peut-être mais voilà c'est assez ancien
sur l'Ukraine la Russie voilà et donc le
voit bien
l'Ukraine alors on verra ce que comment
les choses évolueront dans l'avenir mais
on peut dire aujourd'hui en gros
l'Ukraine revendique d'être une nation
et la Russie
peut pas être autre chose au fond parce
qu'elle ne peut pas être autre chose
qu'un empire la question donc il y a une
opposition profonde qui dépasse
d'ailleurs les questions de régime de
c'est beaucoup plus profond encore que
démocratie contre
dictature c'est c'est médiateur en
milieu de tout ça qui peut être
médiateur entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
mais qui peut parler encore la Russie et
être écouté par l'Ukraine et vice-versa
mais je crois que la question se pose
pas comme ça
d'abord il faut comprendre d'abord il
faut comprendre la question au fond de
la question c'est qui va pouvoir éviter
une des qui va pouvoir limiter
l'escalade et aller dans une dynamique
de désescalade pour cela il faut être
écouté des deux parties être respecté
des deux parties
non où il faut avoir la plus grosse et
dire maintenant tu te tais toi tu te
tais toi
donc comprendre d'abord la profondeur
des des choses c'est à dire que c'est
trop simple de dire c'est le pays de la
liberté contre le camp de la dictature
mais on va faire quoi on va faire la
guerre au chinois on va faire la guerre
aux Indiens on va faire la guerre
on va rentrer en guerre
ça c'est plus facile oui non mais
Luxembourg c'est une démocratie avec une
monarque avec un grand duc mais comme
l'Angleterre c'est pas mais
il y a quelque chose de plus c'est comme
la Chine c'est je veux dire la Chine
c'est quelque chose de plus que la que
le régime chinois voilà il y a des
déterminants qui s'étaient de la
géographie à l'histoire à la culture à
la à l'anthropologie même qui sont pas
séparéductibles simplement à la
différence de de régime et ça on est
obligé de le prendre en compte sinon on
ne prend pas cette réalité en compte on
passe à côté de tout quand le général de
Gaulle a dit la Russie boira le
communisme comme un buveur les imbéciles
ont rigolé
mais il avait raison mais pourquoi on a
pu se regarder vrai diplomate de
comprendre
pourquoi il y a pas ça parce que nous
vivons une époque d'abord une époque de
support vivant une époque de
superficialité très
très grande
alors on s'est déporté sur le terrain
soit disant de la morale mais comme on
disait tout à l'heure ça n'a rien à voir
avec la morale
la morale qui tue autant la morale qui
détruit autant la morale qui qui n'a
plus de quatre conscience c'est pas de
la morale alors c'est quoi cette draper
dans les standards de la vertu pour
pouvoir mieux enfoncer les lignes
adverse
mais le problème c'est que je pense que
c'est pas seulement c'est pas seulement
c'est une population c'est pas seulement
cynique c'est à dire les gens qui
parlent de Munich sans arrêt c'est pas
simplement
de la morale oui mais j'ai tout le monde
se drape dans les standard de la morale
mais certaines fois ça n'a pas commencé
par nous occuper de nous-mêmes avant de
voilà et après si on ne comprend de
l'autre
c'est déterminant de toute façon on est
obligé on est obligé de compter avec lui
on est obligé de parler avant on pouvait
toujours se dire
bon ben on tire l'adversaire à la guerre
totale mais là il y a il y a des arceaux
nucléaires donc de toute façon
ça ne se passera pas comme ça donc on
est ou bien on prend le risque d'un
conflit peut détruire une partie de
l'humanité
ou bien
on essaie de comprendre ce comment
l'autre pense
voilà ce qu'on fait déjà quand on
commence à faire ça déjà ça va ça va un
peu mieux c'est à dire on a une chance
peut-être de trouver une sortie ça
remonte à quand la dernière fois qu'on a
fait ça
de décider de comprendre l'autre
bah chaque fois qu'on a pas qu'on aille
chaque fois qu'on a évité la qu'on a
évité la guerre par exemple quand
Kennedy à bord de la crise des fusées de
Cuba bien il y a un effort réciproque
pour comprendre l'autre c'est à dire il
y a qu'une d'un côté il y a quelque
chose de l'autre ils sont fous ni l'un
ni l'autre et ils comprennent à un
moment donné que
on va à la catastrophe il y avait
une soviétique comme comme à Washington
des gens qui voulaient qui voulaient la
guerre mais la garde c'est prête à
utiliser prêt à utiliser l'arme
nucléaire donc
il y a deux dirigeants avec leurs
qualités et leurs défauts mais qui se
disent non
voilà et qui finissent par communiquer
par se parler d'une façon ou d'une autre
et on évite la catastrophe on est passé
pas très loin de cette catastrophe
il se parlait
d'une façon ou d'une autre c'est
d'ailleurs Kennedy fera l'année suivante
l'Université de Washington un discours
sur la paix sur expliquer ce que c'est
pourquoi on a on a intérêt à la paix de
quel pays s'agit et pourquoi il faut
jamais mettre en fonction de de
puissance nucléaire
bon et il sera il se fera insulter par
un tas de gens encore
mais ça c'est un exemple
la guerre de Corée ça a été la même
chose rappelez-vous enfin c'est Mac
Arthur qui est
le commandant suprême des forces
américaines en Orient
est envoyé en Corée
avec des forces américaines parce que
les Nord-Coréens
ont pris Séoul vont prendre tout le tout
pays c'est-à-dire les communistes en
fait et
l'armée américaine y va elle repousse
les assaillants puis les Chinois on voit
des renforts mais pas sous l'uniforme
chinoise c'est soi-disant des
volontaires genre brigades international
mais mais très très nombreux qui
submergent les Américains et
et
Mac Arthur dit faut frapper sur le sol
sur le sol chinois
pas vraiment là sinon ça va mal se
terminer et Truman refuse
de même qui refusera d'utiliser l'arme
nucléaire
et le conflit entre MacArthur qui n'est
pas un imbécile pourtant mais qui lui
voit les choses en militaire qui est en
train de se faire
qui voit ses troupes se faire submerger
par
la multitude de chinoise et
Truman refuse et le conflit devient-elle
que Truman fini par limoger MacArthur
il y a une volonté de
pas seulement prendre en compte
l'histoire mais prendre en compte les
réalités de la géopolitique on serait
allé où si les Américains étaient entrés
en Chine
et ça ça MacArthur que pourtant vivre
très intelligent et
qui a été un grand un grand soldat qui
s'est plutôt
c'est plutôt bien débrouillé au Japon
puisqu'il a gouverné en fait de fait le
Japon pendant plusieurs années après la
après la l'invasion du Japon par les
enfin après la défaite japonaise
mais là il résonne sur son lui sur son
sur son théâtre d'opération et Truman
sur sur la carte du monde
comment vous voyez l'escalade avec
l'Ukraine le fait que un coup je
constate que que si on regarde sur un an
l'escalade elle n'a cessé de se produire
et le problème de la guerre c'est que le
problème de la violence en général
réponse
à l'invasion russe quand même oui
d'accord mais
ça nous sert à quoi de c'est pareil donc
je je
sauve mon copain je tue les Allemands
c'est normal ils sont c'est de leur
faute ils sont là ils devraient pas être
là d'accord très bien
faute parce que s'il était pas là il
détruire pas le village
voyez c'est toujours la même histoire
c'est que c'est que
on a rien fait à la veille du conflit
pour l'empêcher
rien
c'est quoi rien c'est qu'est-ce qui
empêché mais ce qu'on a fait d'ailleurs
d'abord ce qu'on a fait
la France et l'Allemagne en 2008
premièrement c'est aller la France et
l'Allemagne mais quel est Hollande qui
disent que ça c'est pas en 2008 ça c'est
en 2014 2014 c'était simplement pour
gagner du temps pour que l'Ukraine se
sont
sais rien j'étais pas dans le secret des
dieux c'est ce qu'a dit Madame Merkel je
me dis Hollande je suis pas sûr qu'à
l'époque c'était
si clair que si clair aussi
machiavélique que ça bon mais
en tout cas les accords de masse
personne ne les a respecté
ni les rues d'un côté ni les Ukrainiens
de l'autre chacun prenant prétexte de
l'action de l'autre pour ne pas les
respecter c'est quand même une guerre
qui a fait beaucoup de morts là aussi on
voit bien que le camp du bien et que la
guerre c'est la guerre c'est-à-dire il y
a des crimes de guerre c'est voilà c'est
le spectacle qu'on voit c'est pas la
peine de se dire c'est que la faute de
l'autre c'est de toute façon dans la
guerre
la guerre est un meurtre généralisé
c'est
on s'étonne qu'il y a des morts dans la
guerre on s'étonne qu'on détruise des
villes dans la guerre
bon donc chacun doit se poser la
question de savoir comment on arrête ça
à force de se dire c'est la faute de
l'autre perdre personne bouge comment on
fait pour l'arrêter cette guerre non
mais d'abord comment on faisait pas lieu
personne n'est allé voir Poutine en
disant bon de toute façon l'Ukraine ne
rentrera pas dans l'OTAN et elle aura
pas dans l'Union européenne donc on va
dans neutralisant on va faire la
solution bridginski encore une fois et
pas un ami de la Russie c'était pas un
ami de la réussite et dire bah voilà on
va
on va choisir la solution finlandaise
alors on peut hurler mais la solution
finlandaise elle a préservé
l'indépendance la souveraineté de la
Finlande pendant des décennies alors
qu'elle est à côté de l'Union soviétique
et
qu'elle était toute destinée à être une
proie
qui a un autre exemple je suis de
l'Autriche
l'Autriche à la recouvré sa souveraineté
parce que dans comme un accord les
Russes les Soviétiques d'un côté les
Occidentaux de l'autre ce sont retirés
ont décidé qu'elle serait neutre
bon sinon j'aurais été un terrain
d'affrontement entre les deux c'est en
tout cas elle était de toute manière
divisée en deux camps avec des des
problèmes enfin des tensions qui étaient
permanentes donc
l'Autriche elle a
survécu à la recouvrait son autre sa
souveraineté et survécu au milieu de
toute cette tension parce qu'elle est
devenue neutre c'est pas se dire c'est
pas une solution scandaleuse et c'est
tant qu'on aurait très bien pu dire ça
et puis dire on va on va travailler
[Musique]
à une solution fédérale pour
statut particulier pour lougan que c'est
le et le Dombasle après après faut dire
mais
la Crimée c'est
ukrainien il faut c'est
ukrainien ah bon
depuis quand c'est ukrainien
depuis 91 en fait puisque avant c'était
l'Union soviétique et que ça n'était
qu'une ça n'était qu'une décision
administrative de rattacher la Crimée à
l'Ukraine la primaire jamais été
particulièrement ukrainienne
si on regarde de 91 ans maintenant et
qu'on transfère on transpose ça à
l'Alsace et la Lorraine
voilà c'est la Lorraine enfin la Moselle
sont restés plutôt longtemps
allemande que que
française la plus il y avait une
histoire très ancienne
qui les mettait dans Saint Empire et pas
dans le pendant le royaume de France bon
ça veut dire
qu'est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui pense
sérieusement aujourd'hui que
séparer la à nouveau la
Crimée de la Russie va
permettre de faire avancer la cause de
la paix
intangibilité des frontières c'est un
très beau principe mais si les
frontières avaient été intangibles
dans les années 1820 1830 Texas il
serait mexicain aujourd'hui
et on peut faire ça je veux dire c'est
la vie du monde c'est à dire que les
frontières sont intangibles quand des
deux côtés on est d'accord pour qu'elle
ne bouge pas
et quand on n'est pas d'accord ben on
commence par la par par essayer de faire
intervenir le droit puis quand le droit
ça marche pas on fait intervenir la
diplomatie puis la diplomatie ça marche
pas fait intervenir l'intimidation le
rapport de force et puis quand ça marche
pas c'est la guerre voilà donc le
la question est quand même celle de
celle des conséquences il y a une très
jolie formule de registre de vrai dans
son petit livre sur De Gaulle à demain
de Gaulle
il dit l'homme détail celui qui veut les
conséquences de ce qu'il veut
ce qui donc en Occident aujourd'hui
veut les conséquences d'une reconquête
de la de la de la Crimée par le question
si on met les conséquences sur la table
et qu'on les assume et qu'on les accepte
très bien
et qui les accepte
qui aujourd'hui des assume personne
ils sont coincés quand même ils sont
partis le la main sur le cœur l'étendard
de la vérité lui on est du camp du Bien
au lieu de faire une force
d'interposition qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire parce qu'on était menacé par
Poutine de le premier qui se met en face
de nous je lui bombes la gueule
on est coincé c'est inextricable cette
situation
vous pouvez savoir vous pouvez dire que
c'est une execcable quand vous avez tout
essayé qu'est-ce qui n'a pas été essayé
rien n'a été essayé
rien du tout qu'est-ce que encore une
fois on pouvait éviter la guerre enfin
je sais pas si on pouvait l'éviter mais
on pouvait faire quelque chose pour
l'éviter en proposant de neutraliser de
neutraliser du crâne
en proposant de trouver un statut pour
le pour le donbasse et pour et pour le
Gance voilà et
en acceptant l'idée que que la Crimée
elle est russe voilà car plus la
population de Crimée ça veut dire que on
renonce à démonter des démonter la
Russie
démonter la Russie la démanteler la
si vous voulez démanteler la Russie il
faut s'attendre à ce que tout ça se
passe très mal
alors mais mais c'est un risque énorme
aussi c'est la question c'est encore une
fois toujours la même c'est qu'est-ce
qui se passe si
la Russie subit une défaite considérable
que le régime tombe d'abord qui remplace
démocrates qui vont remplacer le en
Russie aujourd'hui les forces
susceptibles d'assumer le pouvoir elles
sont pas démocratiques
voilà donc il y a les hyper
nationalistes c'est un risque c'est
mieux c'est moins bien
admettons que on n'est pas sans pas
remplacé par par des gens qui sont prêts
à utiliser n'importe quoi y compris
l'arme nucléaire on va avoir du
plutonium au marché noir ça va être
génial oui bah ça va être génial non
mais ça c'est la suite c'est la suite de
l'histoire
la suite de l'histoire c'est que devient
l'arsenal nucléaire
bactériologique et chimique en plus sont
déstabilise la totalité du de l'Eurasie
je veux dire c'est la chinois prendre
son morceau enfin
est-ce que on a tout à fait conscience
de ce qui se passerait dans ce cas là
voilà c'est des mentholer la Russie
c'est revenir sur un équilibre du monde
pas satisfaisant ou pas mais
il y a des siècles et des siècles enfin
je
voilà c'est c'est ça change tout en
Eurasie Macron assumer ça
mais maintenant c'est toujours pas il
avait une bonne intuition une bonne
intuition disant faut pas l'activer il
faut pas les il faut pas accumuler la
Russie si vous acculé la Russie vous
prenez le risque alors ou qu'elle
s'effondre ou que ou qu'elle ou qu'elle
réagissent de façon enfin par une
escalade terrible c'est c'est
est-ce qu'on est prêt à prendre ce
risque si on n'est pas prêt à le prendre
il fallait d'abord essayer de désamorcer
les choses je ne sais pas si on y sera
arrivé mais quand même alors me dit oui
ben c'est enfin les Ukrainiens ils sont
souverains ils peuvent décider d'entrer
dans le temps non pardon ils sont
souverains pour être candidats
et ce sont les pays de l'OTAN qui
acceptent ou non
à l'unanimité c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'ils sont pas rentrés en 2008 parce
que encore une fois deux pays ont refusé
voilà donc le président français il
avait les moyens de dire ils ont trop
pas de faire Dogan avec les avec les
Suédois
il dit non attends que tant que j'aurais
pas ce que je veux rentrer ou pas
voilà donc personne le train dans la
boue il a 3 bijoux de réfugiés sur son
territoire oui bien sûr non mais voilà
c'est pas des réfugiés qui
réfugient s'en sert s'en est servi
contre contre l'Europe là le problème
c'est les Kurdes parce que les Suédois
accueillent des accueille des cures de
chez eux donc mais en tout cas il bloque
je veux dire la France elle pouvait
bloquer
et je pense que c'est pas faut pas dire
les choses cette façon il faut essayer
il faut essayer de comprendre
qui est en train de se passer c'est que
personne en fait on est confronté à des
gouvernements occidentaux
alors je vais mettre un peu à parler des
pays de l'est parce que eux ils
comprennent ils sont obsédés ils ont
habités par des fantômes terribles de de
leur passé bon très bien donc ils vivent
dans l'art hantise de la Russie leur
présent parce qu'ils ont vu les
opérations russes rien qu'en Angleterre
avec scribal le novic choc
les Français ont démonté un camp
d'espion russe Annecy juste à côté de la
Suisse parce qu'il y a pas de il y a pas
d'espion américain parce qu'il y a pas
de parce que les enfin je veux dire
ça n'existe pas non non ça n'existe pas
les Américains là c'est pas écouté les
chefs d'État du gouvernement mais voilà
je veux dire ça c'est la vie du monde il
y avait pas de il y avait écouté par la
NSA ça lui a fait ni chaud ni froid
je sais pas où on a su ça après mais
voilà mais quand ça se passe qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on expire quelques diplomates
quelques diplomates et puis voilà je
veux dire
tout le monde écoute tout le monde tout
le monde bon mais c'est la vie pendant
pendant la guerre froide c'était le cas
ça a pas heureusement ça n'a pas
déclenché à chaque fois une guerre
mondiale
le
faux profond faut pas aussi non
seulement le monde tel qu'il est mais
les hommes tels qu'ils sont les états
tel qu'ils sont aussi il y a très bien
il y a des espions bon et alors
et alors parce que nous on a pas
d'espion en Russie donc c'est pas gaulé
on se fait moins rigoler
très bien on protège on fonctionne voilà
d'accord il a les Russes empoisonnés des
gens en
Angleterre
j'ai cru comprendre que l'Arabie
Saoudite avait découpé à la tronçonneuse
si ça existe ça existe mais voyez c'est
très intéressant la vie internationale
le président Biden a traité c'était des
criminels et saoudiens etc puis quand le
pétrole ait besoin de pétrole il était
allé en Arabie Saoudite puis la série
quand même la main au prince mais c'est
la vie ça s'appelle un réflexe de Lorent
non ça c'est pas du tout ça quand on
appelle ça salive par soumission
que vous êtes toujours confrontés vous
êtes toujours confronté
encore une fois aux réalités
[Musique]
à la fois de la géopolitique de
l'économie
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
toutes ces guerres
les récentes c'est parce qu'on a une
caste politique qui a besoin de se
maintenir et de maintenir un climat
économique
est-ce que la caste politique américaine
va tanguer est-ce que la caste politique
européenne va tanguer c'est aussi pour
arrondir son électorat et maintenir un
statut économique le plus non
construit toujours des complots des la
politique c'est pas la politique est
beaucoup moins machiavélique qu'on le
pense la plupart des 21e siècle non mais
la politique de tous les siècles c'est
c'est en fait la politique c'est souvent
des surtout alors surtout dans des
démocraties où on n'a pas le temps il y
a des élections régulièrement ou les
gens perdent le pouvoir le regagne
dans la politique elle est hélas c'est
c'est là qu'elle est le pire c'est quand
elle devient purement réactive
il y a beaucoup d'improvisation sauf
quand vous avez un de Gaulle enfin dans
le meilleur des cas de golf ou d'Empire
des cas Staline si j'ai une ping lui il
est pas dans la réactivité il est dans
la longue durée
de à la fois de la Chine éternelle et de
et de son régime voilà alors peut-être
que son régime n'aura pas aussi
longtemps mais
voilà c'est la politique chez nous elle
se fait elle se fait pas avec des
constructions aussi aussi aussi
compliqué qui sont beaucoup les gens qui
voient des complots partout mais c'est
pas ça c'est qui les gens qui voient des
compliments partout il y en a plein les
complotistes là c'est toujours
quelle que soit le sujet de toute façon
c'est un grand complot international
c'est là c'est prêté beaucoup trop aux
hommes politiques en réalité enfin bon
sens après
vieux comme le monde mais alors moi je
détiens pas la vérité je vous donne mon
sentiment pour connaître les les
milieux du milieu du pouvoir les avoir
vu exercer les uns et les autres fier
d'être un amateur quoi je crois non je
crois que le
problème il est il est psychologique
c'est un problème c'est un problème de
caractère c'est à dire que nous avons
aujourd'hui une classe en Occident c'est
pas propre à la France se prendra toute
l'Europe alors je laisse encore une fois
de côté sur ce sujet là de l'Ukraine les
réactions des pays de l'Est enfin des
pays la Pologne ou les pays baltes c'est
qui ont eux des déterminants eux
considèrent le vivre de façon
existentielle bon et on peut très bien
comprendre on n'est pas obligé de
s'aligner toujours sur eux tout
simplement c'est bon mais les anti moi
ce qui me frappe c'est que
les générations précédentes d'hommes
politiques ou dans des tas
c'était des générations dans lesquelles
la plupart des dirigeants
n'étaient pas ne quittez pas
l'approbation de leur père
chaque fois qu'il prenait une décision
c'est-à-dire général de Gaulle on
pouvait traîner dans la boue parce qu'il
sortait de des organes militaires
intégrés de l'OTAN parce qu'il a créé
les vive le Québec libre
au Canada ça lui faisait ni chaud ni
froid Chirac on l'a agonie de d'injures
de exercer celui des pressions terribles
au moment de la guerre en Irak faisait
ni chaud ni froid
François Mitterrand prenez ces décisions
lui-même en fonction de ce qu'il pensait
ce que pensait les autres les autres
chefs d'État doivent ça lui faisait ni
chaud ni froid ça le faisait pas changer
d'avis
c'est si vous voulez c'est donc c'est
une question de caractère voilà c'est
pas une question de complot et
aujourd'hui c'est pas propre au
président de la République française
c'est c'est vrai de tous les dirigeants
européens
ces dirigeants européens ils n'ont pas
du tout le la même force de caractère
ils sont à la
chiquette de l'approbation des autres
dans le regard des autres enfin je veux
dire et quand ils l'ont pas là ils
n'arrivent pas à imaginer qu'il puisse
se retrouver en marge
donc il y en a un qui donne un char
l'autre il en donne deux parce que faut
pas rester en arrière et puis le
troisième il en donne 3 et puis c'était
des chars légers notre idée non mais
attendez moi je vais donner des Charlots
il y a une espèce de
besoin si vous de
d'être dans le alors on a beaucoup eu en
France le cercle de la raison dans le
cercle de la morale c'est il faudra s'en
écarter je crois que la pression
psychologique a subi le président de la
République sur
ces positions il faut pas accumuler la
Russie c'était au moins dans les mots
très raisonnable
très responsable bon on était tels que a
pas supporté voilà il s'est remis dans
le cercle de la morale mais ils sont
tous comme ça et on laisse tout faire
personne n'ose dire à Madame
que que nous trouvons pas son mandat et
que
nous entraîne sur des voies ou pour
lesquelles elle a reçu aucun mandat de
personnes
voilà c'est pas personne parce que je
veux pas critiquer ce contraire on est
dans l'assurance chair permanente
cerveau pour les pour les Américains
pour les Canadiens pour les enfin pour
le monde le Saxon c'est pareil
je ne sais pas ce que ferait aujourd'hui
un dirigeant européen si je trouvais
dans la situation de Kennedy par exemple
je sais pas
je sais pas mais je trouve qu'il y a une
espèce de fuite en avant psychologique
qui est qui est de la chose sans doute
la plus inquiétante de
cette histoire qui est depuis le début
depuis le début c'est-à-dire le encore
une fois le président français aurait
très bien pu la France aurait très bien
pu dire dès le départ même avant la
guerre enfin
moi je m'opposerai à l'entrée de de
l'Ukraine dans le dans l'OTAN je pense
qu'il faut parce que je crois que la
bonne solution c'est dans neutralisation
de de l'OTAN il y avait des arguments
valables pour ça
pourquoi l'a pas fait parce que c'est
presque impensable psychologiquement
d'arriver à supporter la la réaction des
autres à une à une telle
un telle démarche
voilà alors que
on pouvait bloquer
il faut l'unanimité donc
je reconnais que c'était une
c'était très dur à vivre sans doute
voilà mais je constate que que en
d'autres temps
des chefs d'État on fait comment pour
désinstaller des tout ça
tel problème et moi je sais pas comment
on fait pour changer les gens c'est à
dire que c'est voyez bien qu'on est
enfin l'Occident est enfermé dans
il est en train de
[Musique]
détruire sa propre civilisation
bon c'est une auto-destruction
seulement extraordinaire il prétend en
même temps
imposer sa civilisation son modèle sa
démocratie son modèle économique au
monde entier
bon il y a quand même
type distorsion entre les deux donc
contradiction en tout cas
c'est l'Occident n'a pas compris
que à partir de l'effondrement de la fin
de la guerre froide le monde devenait
multipolaire et que vouloir à tout prix
qu'il soit uni polaire avec à sa tête
les États-Unis autour de le camp
occidental ne pouvait ne pouvait pas
fonctionner voilà ça ne pouvait pas
fonctionner ou ça donc ça ça conduit
l'Occident à mener des actions
militaires pour imposer cet ordre du
monde
mais c'est une impasse c'est à dire que
c'est même avec la plus grande armée du
monde vous n'arrivez pas à transformer
l'Afghanistan en démocratie à
occidentale c'est comme ça vous n'y
arrivez pas et vous êtes obligé de
partir la queue entre les jambes comme
la Libye quoi voilà mais la Libye on est
parti délibérément de la Libye non mais
c'est vrai c'est parti perdre son short
nous va enfin
une partie après après
Nicolas Sarkozy a quitté le quitté le
pouvoir c'est la Libye personne n'a
voulu on aurait quand même pu essayer
non pas d'occuper mais de
la Libye fallait la mettre sous mandat
de l'ONU ah je veux dire c'est pour
essayer de rétablir minimum un minimum
d'ordre parce que c'était l'impact sur
le continent mais bien sûr parce que
c'était les conséquences
concernées tout le monde donc voilà donc
on aurait pu essayer on a pas essayé
tout le monde a plié bagages il a dit
débrouillez-vous voilà bah maintenant si
on se débrouille avec les conséquences
aussi voilà mais la Libye on a rien
essayé bon euh
l'Irak on a vu ce que ça a donné
après on a abandonné tout le monde c'est
le Vietnam c'est l'Afghanistan l'Irak
bon les Balkans je suis pas sûr que
l'indépendance du Kosovo était une
réussite et surtout on a donné en plus
au monde l'image de de
pays qui
voulait imposer au monde des règles en
particulier de droit international
qu'il ne respectait pas même
voilà c'est le Kosovo est en dehors de
tout droit international
on pourrait juger que c'était moralement
c'est pareil c'est pas de mandat de qui
que ce soit l'Afghanistan non plus on
fait comment pour arrêter tous bordel on
mobilise les populations civiles pour
influencer notre propre politique mais
ça d'abord premièrement les populations
civiles dans les démocraties
mais même dans les autres régimes
d'ailleurs elles ont leur rôle à jouer
c'est si elle veulent pas quelque chose
elles ont rien dire les manifester moi
les populations vont souffre en ce
moment oui bien sûr elles sont
pratiquement en catatonie émotionnelles
parce que il y a la récession il y a la
guerre il y a l'inflation et les
problèmes de travail il y a de la
violence climatique et les problèmes
climatiques et tout ça comment comment
la population civile peut avoir encore
l'énergie
pour éviter ah oui mais c'est si les
peuples n'ont pas d'énergie pour se pour
survivre et se défendre
disparaissent
donc il va bien falloir que les peuples
notamment en Europe de notre en
particulier trouvant lui-même l'énergie
nécessaire pour ce pour se défendre et
se redresser alors parfois il suffit de
quelques-uns pour pour entraîner tout le
reste
mais quand même voilà faut qu'il y ait
une source d'énergie quelque part sinon
sinon ça sinon ça ça marche pas et et
d'abord contre la France pouvait avoir
un rôle pour aller dans cette direction
qu'elle a toujours eu
et que là elle n'exerce pas alors encore
une fois je reconnais que la pression
est très forte mais faut bien comprendre
ça c'est pas un problème à la française
mais oui bien sûr mais c'est
là c'est pas un problème de l'idéologie
là on voit bien c'est pas c'est pas les
grands dessins de pays européens ils
n'en ont pas de grands dessins ils vont
être les premiers victimes de tout ce
qui se passe que la Russie gagne ou
qu'elle perde voilà parce que si elle
gagne elle va aller jusqu'à la frontière
polonaise ou à la moitié du crâne donc
vous allez avoir tous les pays de l'Est
qui vont vivre dans le trans
des Américains qui vont ils vont leur
salet des bases de partout sur le long
de la du du c'est comme le limace de
Rome
voilà et puis le
de l'Europe va basculer va basculer vers
l'Est les Américains vont vous font
diriger l'Europe enfin je veux dire
voilà et en plus l'Europe soit non c'est
pas encore le cas heureusement mais mais
ça vient quoi je dirais parce que
parce que les Européens
ne réagissent pas ils sont ils sont vous
les faire l'Europe pour être
indépendants entre les empires ah c'est
réussi
voilà mais c'est pareil on avait fait la
monnaie unique pour être plus prospère
faut voir ce qui a été la prospérité de
l'Europe depuis depuis 92 on avait fait
l'Europe pour être plus plus libre plus
démocratique plus voilà on n'a jamais eu
autant de bureaucratie on n'a jamais
autant foulé au pied les libertés
individuelles est-ce que ça ressemble à
l'effondrement de Rome
avec une bureaucratif il faut
se méfier des des analogies
mais
ça ressemble en tout cas à la
décomposition d'une civilisation je
trouve que
si on voit bien ce qui se passe avec le
avec le hoquisme
avec enfin
qu'est-ce que vous reprochez au petit
book parce que je reproche
mais je leur reproche un de marcher sur
la tête et de vouloir que tout le monde
marche sur la tête
voilà c'est quand même extraordinaire
c'est oui mais faut voir les gens qui en
sont victimes c'est quoi c'est pas si
vous avez vu je sais pas si vous avez vu
sûrement vous avez sûrement vu ça le
petit documentaire qui traîne sur
internet sur Evergreen le collège
premier anniversaire américaine ou qui a
qui a dévoilé la montée vous avez
absolument passionnant c'est vous voyez
la naissance d'un totalitarisme sur un
campus universitaire c'est très
intéressant et ça a fait d'ailleurs un
scandale à l'époque aux États-Unis voilà
c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas une petite histoire qui
restait dans l'ombre et qu'on manipule
c'est c'est voilà il faut voir faut voir
on vient des gens on les expulse de de
de de de de spectacle
on brûle des livres au Canada on brûle
des livres pour enfants parce que
parce que bah ils sont pas bien la façon
dont on parle dans Astérix des
Indiens sont des des indices comment on
appelle
population je sais plus comment il faut
les appeler mais on disait les
Amérindiens mais c'est plus le mot c'est
pas le mot c'est plus bon mot
le livre natif
peut-être d'autres voilà on voulait les
livres on a
extraordinaire en Angleterre là ils
veulent réécrire des
je vais leur écrire des livres pour
enfants
d'auteurs qui sont morts déjà depuis des
années qui ont un succès fou
fantastique c'est enfin il y a quelque
chose qui se passe là qui est quand même
étonnant je parle pas du reste je parle
pas de la
du féminisme qui dérape dans n'importe
quoi
quand même c'est on est parti de mes 68
l'excès de c'est quoi le féminisme qui
est très intéressant n'importe quoi on
est parti de Mai 68 avec un excès de
il est interdit d'interdire de de on est
allé très loin d'aller jusqu'à la
poologie de la pédophilie c'est quand
même pas mal puisque ça ne choqué
personne il y a encore 20 ans bon et
puis maintenant on se retrouve dans une
période non dans une période de
puritanisme
côté duquel comme moi elle aurait été
jugée très modérée quoi
le plus extraordinaire c'est que quand
Poutine dit dénonce cet aspect de la
société occidentale dont il veut pas
l'importation
qui dit c'est pour rendre compte par un
ou la fait le coup ça a provoqué des
réactions au moment l'éducation
nationale voulait que sur les
formulaires il n'y a plus que par un
parent de
bon ben trouver que c'est normal qu'il y
a
voilà que ceux qui veulent s'appeler par
un parent de le fasse très bien pour au
moins réserver une case à périmètre en
dessous c'est pas ah non non il a fallu
il a fallu que ça déclenche un scandale
pour pour revenir là-dessus c'est quoi
du mariage homosexuel non mais moi j'ai
mis des contre voilà ce palme j'ai mis
des contre à l'époque et pourquoi mais
j'ai imité compte pourquoi parce que la
question qui était posée
pas une question
psychologique religieuse c'est une
question anthropologique c'est-à-dire
que la question qui est posée celle de
l'affiliation le mariage a été inventé
dans l'histoire non pas par une religion
particulière mais existe dans toutes les
sociétés pour mettre de l'ordre dans la
filiation parce que une société a besoin
c'est le démarrage d'une société besoin
d'une de mettre de l'ordre dans la
filiation savoir qui descend de qui qui
est le fils de qui voilà
j'ai été fait pour ça
pourquoi
casser
cette institution c'est à dire pourquoi
casser la filiation
pourquoi mettre du désordre dans dans
l'affiliation
voilà qui va d'ailleurs avec l'idée
qu'il y a plus de différence de sexe il
y a plus c'est juste en construit social
et tout ça ça est un ensemble terrifiant
moi j'ai été élevé par deux femmes
ma mère et ma grand-mère
je peux vous dire je sais ce que ça veut
dire l'absence de l'absence de père
Ali est assez il y en a j'ai été très
heureux mais je sais ce que c'est il y a
assez d'accidents de la vie qui vous
impose ce genre de situation pour pas
qu'on en rajoute voilà c'est c'est tout
ça ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'homosexualité c'est juste que je
moi mon combat c'était l'affiliation
voilà et je continue une pensée que ça a
été une profondeur mais revenons
revenons sur votre perception de la
destruction de la société occidentale
après on nous a dit mais on touchera pas
à la PMA
pour tous
la médecine c'est fait pour ça c'est
nouveau
un gage mais on verra mais je suis pas à
prendre les paris que vous l'aurez aussi
mais on s'est demandé que dans quelle
civilisation nous allions vivre vous
êtes posé la question aussi de la
souffrance d'un coup homosexuel qui
voudrait avoir un enfant
oui il y a aussi la souffrance des gens
qui naissent qui naissent fier qui sont
pas garçons il y a aussi mais moi j'ai
pas souffert et alors j'ai pas demandé à
la société de réparer ma souffrance
enfin je veux dire il y a aussi des
données de la nature qui sont enfin
c'est extraordinaire enfin la souffrance
mais oui il faut un homme et une femme
donc dès lors que vous décidez que on
peut faire un enfant entre deux hommes
et deux femmes ou deux hommes ou de
femmes
vous créez un
problème majeur
voilà mais encore une fois la souffrance
c'est de la relève de la psychologie bon
l'anthropologie c'est autre chose c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus profond
des gens qui souffrent il y en a tous
les jours c'est pas parce que vous c'est
pas parce que vous souffrez qu'il faut
laisser toute la société sur votre
souffrance
moi je
trouve ça honnêtement hallucinant
c'était ça il y avait c'était très
intéressant il y avait un
député de gauche j'ai oublié le nom qui
venait des Antilles qui avaient fait un
discours qui était contre bon c'est pas
d'accord avec ça sans trop de famille
politique il a fait un discours
expliquant moi je suis indécendant
d'esclaves voilà ce qu'on est en train
de faire c'est pas bien c'est fait
agonir d'un jour mais il y avait rien
là-dedans de d'homophobe de rien du tout
il y avait ça aussi ça sa propre sa
propre perception de la souffrance et de
ce que devait être une société compte
tenu de ce qui avait été l'expérience de
son de son peuple de son ethnie de enfin
je sais pas il y avait un couple
homosexuel qui veut un enfant qu'est-ce
qu'on fait alors ils ont ici
mais vous dit qu'il veut il veut Il veut
et alors je veux dire il veut
mais ça veut dire quoi je veux un enfant
mais l'enfant je veux un enfant vous
avez besoin d'un homme et d'une femme
voilà c'est c'est
on est au 21e siècle non
ça change rien d'être 21e siècle c'est
ça le problème que nous avons c'est nous
avons oublié une chose nous avons oublié
que la nature ne change pas et que la
nature humaine ne change pas non plus
donc quand on oublie ça on oublie les
fondements même d'une société je parle
même pas de la civilisation c'est à dire
que les sociétés elles ont trouvé au fil
des millénaires des arrangements pour
permettre de vivre ensemble le moins mal
possible
et on considère que ah bah nous on est
fantastiques ah bon on n'est pas comme
les autres ah ben nous on est on a
changé on a une mutation anthropologique
extraordinaire nous on peut faire ce
qu'on veut on peut on peut jouer aux
apprentis sorciers c'est non non c'est
très bien d'ailleurs c'est c'est
magnifique on va faire le transhumanité
transhumanisme on va faire c'est
extraordinaire et puis c'est pareil il y
aura plus de guerre vous verrez il y
aura
bien sûr et puis tout le monde est pour
la démocratie pour revenir à notre sujet
c'est exactement la même chose que
la après la après les fondrement de la
de l'Union soviétique la fin de la
guerre froide on a dit ah ben c'était
c'est la fin de l'histoire
tout le monde aspire tous les hommes
aspirent à liberté la démocratie le
marché le truc c'est bon c'est bon du
soir est fini hein vous allez voir c'est
plus qu'une question de temps là
maintenant c'est fini mais non tous les
hommes n'aspirent pas à la même vision
de l'homme que fouille
c'est non les autres ne pensent pas tous
comme nous
c'est une donnée éternelle c'est que ils
ont pas tous pareils voilà est-ce qu'on
a oublié de s'accorder sur les
désaccords
on est irréconciliable les uns avec les
autres mais non mais ça dépend sur quoi
vous touchez
voilà maintenant c'est fait
il est là très bien pas des bas on va
pas on va pas
on va pas faire subir aux enfants on
sort voilà on va pas démarrer les gens
on va pas pour très bien je pense que
c'était je j'ai mené ce combat moi
en toute conscience et je pense que
c'était un bon combat je pense que c'est
une erreur voilà et je pense que que
l'Occident d'erreur en erreur fini non
seulement par s'auto détruire en tant
que de civilisation et en tant que
société
il veut
imposer son modèle résumé vous avez vu
ce qu'on pense le reste du monde enfin
voilà ça c'est comme le communautarisme
vous pouvez me dire ah bah oui en
communauté bah très bien voilà en France
on vit pas en communauté il y a des
endroits il y a des pays qui pensent que
le communautarisme c'est très bien
en Angleterre oui mais je m'en fous moi
je suis pas en anglais je suis pas
anglais je pense qu'ils veulent en
Angleterre ça pose pas de problème la
communautarisme dans tous les pays qui
ont choisi de communautarisme maintenant
il y a des problèmes parce que le
commune terrible ça favorise évidemment
le conflit entre les communautés ça fait
des sociétés beaucoup plus instables ça
fait des sociétés
pourquoi c'est mieux c'est fantastique
voilà non la France elle s'est
construite sur la simulation très bien
moi
je tiens la simulation bah on n'est pas
d'accord on est pas d'accord mais mais
je lâcherai jamais je me souviens de
gens qui disaient l'assimilation de
sinistre mémoire mais quoi c'est
peut-être pour vous d'asser son mémoire
pour moi la simulation ça a été ça a été
une idée absolument
génial enfin
je n'imagine pas de vivre dans une
société qui ne défend pas l'assimilation
question internet selon Henri Guaino
qu'est-ce que le féminisme extrême
pas de féminisme extrême c'est celui qui
dit par exemple
s'il y a 100 plainte de pour viol il
doit y avoir sans condamnation
sans enquête
maintenant
c'est ce que disait qu'Internet avant de
se faire prendre
dans les violences conjugales le soupçon
suffit
voilà moi j'appelle ça le j'appelle ça
un extrémisme ce terrible mais c'est
pareil c'est pas parce qu'on est dénoncé
non plus que
que c'est vrai et que la justice peut
peut dire c'est toujours vrai c'est pas
vrai
voilà donc il faut faire des enquêtes il
faut ça mais il faut pas il faut pas
expliquer que dès qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui est relaxé c'est une honte il se
peut qu'il soit innocent
le nombre de nanas qui appelle les
policiers qui se font envoyer chier qui
finissent
qui finissent très très mal avec leur
conjoint vous avez pas vu derrière moi
le flic lui a dit régler vos problèmes
on verra ça plus tard il lui raccroche
au nez
ça c'est scandaleux c'est pas comme
enfin que ça soit pour les violences
conjugales que ça soit pour pour
n'importe quoi maintenant
ça c'est le travail de l'état de faire
respecter un certain nombre de règles
maintenant il faut voir aussi les moyens
qu'on donne les moyens qu'on donne aux
gens enfin nos policiers les la façon
dont la justice
l'enregistrement des plaintes ça sent le
pipi partout ils ont rien ils ont des
véhicules tout pourri mais voilà c'est
bien mais c'est pas grave pendant des
années on a fait des décennies on a fait
des politiques d'austérité on a fait
voilà tout le monde on a la gauche
centre tout le monde ah c'est très bien
continuons alors on se rend compte qu'on
a aussi démoli l'armée et que peut-être
qu'on pourra en avoir besoin c'est
fantastique
l'armée a testé pendant des décennies
qu'elle se faisait démolir là là on lui
a combien doublés triplés le budget
combien
on va essayer d'arriver à 2% du du pub
pour ça
plus obligé de cirer les roues des
vagues le 14 juillet
c'est bien que
pas le problème ce problème c'est c'est
de savoir quelle armée on a ce qu'on a
une armée qui peut être capable de
défendre de pays où est-ce qu'on a juste
une armée de d'intervention extérieure
c'était qui dans une guerre dans une
guerre à haute intensité aurait trois
jours de munition et
pourrait défendre que 80
frontières de 80 km
mais mais tout est comme ça on a enfin
vu on a tout cassé
casser c'est un objectif en soi on a
casser l'école bon on a cassé l'armée on
a voilà on a réduit la justice à la
pauvrissement
matériel pareil pour la police
les profs ont gagné de gagner plus
gagner 2,2 SMIC à peu près au début des
années 80 gagne aujourd'hui un virgule
un virgule deux SMIC
et après on s'étonne de pas en trouver
les infirmières les hôpitaux les
infirmières les hôpitaux les médecins
c'est bien moi quand j'étais jeune
médecin généraliste c'était un notable
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas 25 euros
la consultation
alors dans certaines rencontrer reculées
quand ils veulent y aller ça peut
permettre de vivre un peu mieux mais
quand vous êtes dans une grande
métropole ça devient très très juste
tout ça pour disons d'études et la
responsabilité de
du diagnostic des malades
mais tout est comme ça tout est comme ça
et ça continue d'ailleurs on dit quand
même les régimes spéciaux des cheminots
on trouve plus on trouve plus
c'est le moment qu'on décide de
l'enlever dernier avantage et on les
compense pas rien ah bah oui mais c'est
pas bien mais c'est pas bien vous c'est
privilégié d'accord
vous allez conduire les trains
les bus les bus c'est encore pire
surtout que les bus en place on passe un
temps de marcher sous-traitance avec des
entreprises privées
qui rogne surtout
mais vous trouvez plus de choses
plus assez les infirmières pareil mais
c'est pareil pareil c'est donc un moment
alors après on vous dit veulent pas
travailler bah d'accord il y en a qui
veulent pas travailler mais
s'il n'y a pas de reconnaissance
matérielle si vous êtes obligé de tirer
la langue tout le temps
la réforme des retraites Macron il nous
fait ça parce qu'il est un peu frustré
avec sa politique extérieure est obligée
de se venger sur sa politique intérieure
est-ce que
entre ce que ce qui se passe en Europe
sur le conflit ukrainien les sanctions
qu'on prend qui nous sont
nous-mêmes voilà c'est des Russes sont
transformés en économie de guerre ils
ont une résilience beaucoup plus grande
que
nous plus une société sophistiquée plus
elle est fragile moins les les
résistances voilà donc
puis à l'inflation c'est tout ça c'est
fantastique c'est il se passe rien quoi
on fait des chèques alimentaires c'est
extraordinaire et ceux qui ont pas les
chèques là déjà chaque alimentaire ça
couvre pas tout mais ce qui en ont pas
qu'est-ce qu'ils font
ils tapent dans leur épargne quand ils
sont non
attendez c'est le problème c'est que
faut manger quoi c'est une fois toutes
les charges fixes sont payées la
variable d'ajustement c'est la
nourriture ça va durer combien de temps
les fringues oui les fringues aussi mais
les fringues ça peut les porter entendre
la nourriture c'est
voilà c'est pas grave c'est tout ça
absolument pas grave comme un cron dit
supermarché de chaîne de supermarché il
faut arrêter je dirais de faire de la
faire de la politique économique c'est
pas dire vous gagnez trop vous gagnez
pas assez il faut être plus modéré non
soit on considère qu'il gagne trop et en
l'état
je finis ma phrase OK
quand Macron demande à Leclerc et ses
copains de faire un
panier pas cher
c'est parce qu'il veut pas afficher le
fait que il va falloir bientôt faire
comme dans les pays du tiers-monde
c'est-à-dire sponsoriser les temps
réalimentaires de base parce que quand
même pour l'image de la France ça craint
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui se passe les
matières alimentaires de base
ils ont pris très cher
lui la farine le sucre je sais pas
ça pique pourquoi enfin moi je
veux pas résoudre le problème en réalité
comme dans tout le reste on se fout du
monde
soit que du monde sur la guerre mais ça
c'est très grave mais en ce moment du
monde aussi sur l'inflation commencement
du monde sur les retraites
enfin je
il y a pas un problème de pouvoir
d'achat et de salaire
ça ne c'est pas important
alors on va faire un panier on fait un
chèque et la question des salaires est
posée ou pas on accepte dans des battre
et d'y réfléchir
ou on attend que ça finisse par sauter
parce que les gens ils vont plus
il faut comprendre c'est bien gentil de
dire admettons que l'inflation dans un
an et demi elle soit à zéro ou dans deux
ans déjà perdu
voilà vous auriez perdu peut-être 15 à
20% pouvoir d'achat
voire plus voire plus mais même pour ça
enfin
vous allez voir les gens à dire je
baisse votre salaire de 15% de 20%
le cadre dirigeant d'une grande
entreprise que ce soit quelque chose ça
va c'est pas mon problème mais pour la
plupart des gens si on leur dit même les
cadres une baisse de 20% votre salaire
je pense que
vous êtes très compliqué quand même et
non on fait comme si qu'en inflation
était à zéro il s'est pas passé
c'est pas se moquer du monde
voilà c'est pourquoi on peut pas
pourquoi on ne peut pas débattre de
l'indexation des salaires
parce que ça ferait monter l'inflation
d'abord ce discours on l'a tenu sur
les mesures sociales depuis qu'il existe
des mesures sociales c'est toujours
ça fera monter l'inflation
j'ai regardé c'est en Belgique on index
beaucoup plus qu'en France
c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui il faut un peu moins
d'inflation qu'en Allemagne où il y a
pas d'indexation déjà
déjà ça se discute mais même
c'est la situation dans laquelle
les salaires sont pas indexés c'est une
situation à la fin intenable donc où ils
s'indexeront parce qu'il y aura des
lieux sociales des et puis on peut faire
autrement mais dans un climat dans un
climat détestable de relation sociale ou
bien ou bien les index indexation
d'ailleurs ne couvre pas la totalité
puisque l'indice des prix à la
consommation il faut pas la totalité de
l'inflation mais mais
si vous le faites pas d'abord les
finances publiques qui sont déjà dans un
état
dramatique et moi je suis pas maniaque
de de
l'équipe budgétaire de Smic quand même
l'inflation en général ça vous rende
dette
uniquement si les revenus augmentent
mais s'il est revenu au mental ça
alourdit le poids de la dette
pour le pour la pour celui qui est
endetté
voilà quand on dit l'inflation en 2 ans
c'est l'inflation la vraie
ce qu'on appelle l'inflation en économie
c'est-à-dire la hausse du niveau général
des prix de tous les prix y compris y
compris le prix du travail
mais si c'est pas le cas si c'est pas le
cas dans l'état il va gagner un peu plus
sur la sur la TVA mais c'est tout
quasiment
si vous indexer des salaires c'est c'est
toute l'assiette des prélèvements
obligatoires qui s'index à condition
évidemment d'indexer aussi la baronne de
l'impôt sur le revenu
si vous indexez des salaires
pouvoir d'achat il augmente pour tout le
monde c'est-à-dire c'est si vous passez
dans raisonnement microéconomique et
raisonnement macroéconomique bon
ça devient supportable et à ce moment-là
il faut s'intéresser aux causes de
l'inflation
mais les gens qui le subissent ils vont
finir par s'intéresser à ceux qui font
genre de politique c'est voilà et à ceux
qui gagnent qui font beaucoup de profits
qu'il faut faire vous allez voir c'est
c'est
on cherche quoi restituer on veut
ressusciter la lutte des classes on veut
quoi
on veut quoi on veut on veut que
réveiller la démocratie démocratie
disparaissent
il y a un moment où ça n'est pas tenable
des principales sources de l'inflation
à part les sanctions
au mieux
ne pas parler mais qui sont en train de
détruire l'économie européenne l'énergie
c'est extraordinaire quand même les
factures d'électricité qui augmentent
mais nous on produit de l'électricité
pas cher
voilà on est on est obligé de rester
dans le marché unique d'électricité
[Musique]
le marché unique de l'électricité on
vous explique on peut pas en sortir
l'argument magnifique c'est il y a des
interconnexions alors sinon quand on
aura besoin d'être président d'en aura
pas ce sera le blackout mais c'est mais
ça c'est se moquer du monde
ça n'a rien à voir ça s'appelle être
dans l'air du temps mais oui mais ça
n'est pas une question d'opinion on peut
dire je veux pas parce que il y a des
problèmes politiques avec mes voisins je
veux bien mais pas me dire ça n'est pas
possible
si c'est possible il faut juste de la
volonté
de continuer comme ça voilà on a enfin
pour qu'on a fait ça je veux dire mais
tout le monde est coupable c'était c'est
un monopole naturel l'électricité il
fallait le laisser en monopole naturel
on construit de l'électricité on fait de
l'électricité pas cher si on a besoin
dans n'importe un peu à certains moments
si vous importez 10 % de votre
consommation et qu'elle vous l'importer
très cher ça fera que dit que 10% du
prix de revient je vous rappelle qu'on
était un petit peu à la rue avec nos
réacteurs avant l'hiver oui alors on
aurait importé mais on était à la rue
pourquoi il faut revenir à ce que tout
ce qu'on a fait sur la filière nucléaire
et vous avez reçu pour Guillaume il vous
a expliqué voilà c'est un petit peu il y
aura de quoi on peut vous pourrez passer
trois heures sur la question
c'est une question que je bon ça fait
deux heures qu'on est ensemble
on continue on continue pas qu'est-ce
qu'on fait
waouh 10 minutes un quart d'heure
si vous voulez plus non
on va tourner en rond et
on va mériter la punition le coup de
bâton de du retour à la réalité
parce que le réchauffement climatique
parce que quand même votre génération
ça y est le réchauffement climatique le
monde qu'on laisse à nos enfants la
pollution partout
l'épuisement des ressources fossil
minières animal
léguer
l'inflation tout partout la dislocation
géopolitique mondiale la reconstruction
de certains blocs
votre génération c'était la meilleure en
fait la
générations qui ont suivi la mienne
elles ont fait la même chose en pire
c'est la mienne à ça mais non pas de
responsabilité
mais tout le monde par des
responsabilité quand on a quand on a
fait le marché une électricité quand on
a inventé de de subventionner les
concurrents de EDF pour qu'ils puissent
faire mieux faire concurrence à EDF
quand on a fait des politiques
d'austérité absurdes c'est personne à
protester
quelques-uns quand même non mais très
peu enfin non il y a pas eu de vous
savez ce qui se passait quand les
électriciens procession c'était
privilégiés c'est pas notre problème
c'est partout comme ça quand c'était les
soignants c'est pareil soignants et
protestaient
Jean-Luc Mélenchon non pas du tout
pourquoi
pourquoi moi je suis pas
anti-capitaliste quand même non avec le
Parti communiste
prochaine élections votez mélanges
parce que ça n'a pas de sens qui veut
pas dire que tout est idiot
à droite la gauche centre je m'en fiche
mais ça c'est terrible aussi c'est que
on revient toutes les poutous
de de qui soit susceptible de résoudre
les problèmes je veux dire c'est entre
Poutou et général de Gaulle moi je
choisis le général de Gaulle voilà entre
Poutou et Pompidou choisis Pompidou
voilà bon c'est pas enfin tout ça tout
ça n'a pas de tout ça n'a pas de sens le
capitalisme c'est le nom qu'on donne à
la civilisation matérielle de l'Occident
puis au moins le 14e siècle bon on a
essayé on a essayé d'en sortir on a vu
ce que ça donnait
c'est comme le marché on en revient à la
question de la limite si vous voulez
mettre le marché partout la concurrence
partout pour résoudre tous les problèmes
ça ne marche pas et d'ailleurs aucune
société n'a fait ça et n'a pu faire ça
si vous le remettre nulle part bon ben
ça vous donne l'Union soviétique au
mieux ou la Chine de Mao bon on sait
maintenant et tant qu'il faut se fixer
des limites il faut du marché mais il
faut pas que du marché il faut de l'État
il faut pas que de l'État et voilà on
cherche à mettre le curseur en fonction
de l'état des techniques de des
circonstances de l'époque dans laquelle
on on vit on se fixant des limites même
quand on a un adepte du marché même
quand on est pour capitalisme même quand
on est pour le libéralisme même quand on
est pour le socialisme et si on se met
pas de limite ça ne marche pas et ça
conduit à des drames voilà je vais vous
dire je vais vous dire une question
commentaire d'Internet
de la part de Jérémy
est-ce que Henri Guaino se rend compte
qu'il est la définition même du boomer
il est bloqué dans un monde qui n'existe
plus dans 10 ou 20 ans il ne sera plus
là
il a aucune idée de ce que ressemblera
le monde dans 30 ans ma question quel
est son but il croit que dans 50 ans la
société devrait être la même qu'il y a
50 ans il me donne juste l'image d'un
mec qui a vécu dans une époque qui n'est
clairement pas la même que la nôtre donc
son avis est-il pertinent
ah mais je cherche je sais pas si il est
pertinent ça c'est à l'internaute en
juger
façon dont il en juge mais lui
appartient ne fera pas changer d'avis
parce que la nôtre je suis encore vivant
donc c'est aussi la mienne l'époque
c'est la première des choses c'est
pardon mais le monde je l'ai vu changer
autant que lui mais ça ça me rappelle ça
me rappelle les gens qui pendant tout à
l'heure de la à l'époque de la du
mariage pour tous Je me disait mais le
modèle familial traditionnel ça n'excuse
vous savez je dis je sais oui moi j'ai
jamais vécu dans le domaine donc si je
voulais
pas que le monde ne change pas il change
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
matins vous levez avec mon nouveau mais
il y a une chose qui ne change pas et
que votre internaute sur lequel de votre
intérieur devrait réfléchir Jérémy c'est
la nature de l'homme la nature humaine
elle ne change pas voilà il y a des gens
qui pensent que si moi je pense que non
voilà et je regarde l'histoire je pense
que l'histoire elle nous donne pas de
recette sur l'avenir mais elle nous
apprend ce que nous sommes
renoncer à ça renoncer à tout ce qui
constitue une barrière pour empêcher
l'animalité de l'homme de sortir
et elle sort chaque fois que ça
s'affaibli d'ailleurs on n'a pas de
recette définitive mais si on ne fait
pas d'effort
pour pour l'empêcher de sortir elle sort
et chaque fois que les barrières se sont
affaiblis chaque fois qu'on a traversé
une crise de civilisation elle est
sortie
on peut recommencer moi je mets ça ça va
pas changer la preuve il y aurait plus
de guerre
on se retrouve quoi avec des avec Verdun
on porte de l'Europe
c'est fini ça c'était impensable les
tranchées les gens qui le rasés
impensable
de l'Europe la pandémie mais il est il
est gentil Jérémy moi j'ai vécu de
l'intérieur toutes ces mutations et
toutes les aberrations qu'on a on a
produit pendant des années sont pas le
fait de la mutation anthropologique de
l'homme quand on parlait de l'armée elle
est toujours comme disait bon il faut
peut-être changer il faut ça travaille
une armée un peu plus
un modèle d'armée qui soit un peu plus
qu'un éventail un peu plus large de
toujours quelqu'un pour dire
mais il est pas menacé
vous avez quelle menace
ah bah maintenant se pose plus la
question
quand on parlait de pandémie
ça c'est fini là c'est pour les pays du
c'est pour les pays sous-développés en
fait personne n'y croyait un tas de
rapport d'experts de gens qui disaient
attendez il y a un danger il y a un
risque mais on s'en fiche
on avait créé un établissement les
brusques qui établissement pour la
gestion des
urgences sanitaires ça veut des crises
sanitaires la première la première
raison des crises sanitaires enfin la
première instrument de gestion de crise
sanitaire c'est c'est la logistique
c'est l'organisation matérielle on était
en short
santé publique France qui n'était pas du
tout la culture de de la gestion
logistique d'organisation c'est plutôt
militaire bon c'est
quoi ça c'est ça ça va ça va changer
c'est bêtises là c'est quoi c'est le
changement c'est le changement
tropologique du monde qui a fait que
dans ce monde là dans ce monde nouveau
merveilleux extraordinaire qui est en
train de ressembler un très vieux monde
c'est ça qui a fait que on a supposé des
minutes de tous les moyens
c'est ça qui a fait qu'on a menti du
début jusqu'à la fin sur les meilleures
façons de combattre la combattre la
pandémie
la meilleure façon de convaincre la
pandémie c'était sans de s'occuper des
groupes les plus les plus vulnérables
mais ce qui est frappant c'est la dérive
totale du scientisme dans cette affaire
quand vous vous émettiez une critique
vous proposez une question vous y
répondez c'est ah non non mais c'est
scientifique
c'est fantastique c'est scientifique moi
j'ai entendu des responsables de grands
organismes de santé français expliquer
que ils avaient démontré qu'on se qu'on
se on se contaminait dans les
restaurants
ah bon vous avez démontré vous allez
voir moi je curiosité de aussi
d'économiste voilà les statistiques que
j'aime bien et vous vous rendez compte
que d'abord c'était une enquête
déclaratoire
déclarative voilà non mais ça démontre
vous avez fait un échantillon
représentatif il y a 80% des gens qui
ont pas répondu
et donc on note en bas de page est écrit
logiquement d'ailleurs
les auteurs des précautions mais quand
il venaient sur les plateaux c'était
plus pareil bah oui c'est plus un
échantillon
et en plus quand vous répétez toute la
journée à des gens que c'est dans les
restaurants qu'on se contamine et que
vous leur demandez après d'après vous
vous êtes contaminés ou
est-ce que répondre ah ben je suis allé
au restaurant c'est là mais ça c'est
intéressant c'est quoi ça c'est
tout ça c'est quoi la statistique
l'économétrie le la physique la médecine
tout ça ça
a tellement changé sur le fond la
science par exemple ce qu'est la science
il a tellement changé que je comprends
plus rien ce qui se passe parce que moi
j'ai vécu dans un monde où c'était
tellement différent mais non mais là
l'idée même de sciences elle a pas
changé les exigences de la science à la
pas changer savoir que la science c'est
pas la vérité mais que c'est une méthode
pour essayer d'atteindre une vérité
qu'on atteint jamais ça change
ça change il peut réfléchir Jérémy à ça
on t'énerve pas non je m'énerve pas mais
cette histoire-là le monde que nous
sommes en train de construire parce que
le monde il parait par hasard qu'il est
bon pour ton cœur ça c'est vrai mais le
monde il est pas ce qu'il est par hasard
est-ce qu'il est parce que nous le
construisons comme ça avec à la fois les
erreurs que nous avons commises les
réussites mais c'est nous qui le
construisons
mais c'est c'est plus le même pourquoi
parce que vous êtes plus pareil que moi
vous êtes plus fait pareil
c'est extraordinaire moi je le regarde
ce monde il ressemble au monde d'avoir
le mien enfin celui qui pense être le
mien c'est-à-dire celui des 30 glosses
glorieuses moi je les ai achevé quand je
suis rentré dans la vie d'adulte je
voilà c'est pas fait longtemps mais il
ressemble au monde d'avant les 30
glorieuses
quand vous faites à déréglementation
financières
moi je travaillais dans la banque à
l'époque où on a
on a on a créé ce monde on a créé mais
ce qu'on a créé c'était ce qui avait ce
qui existait avant la grande crise des
années 30 c'est ce qui existait à la fin
du 19e siècle
c'est extraordinaire quoi
vous prenez n'importe quel livre faisons
l'histoire des cris financière puisque
c'est un sujet qui vous passionne
c'est la conclusion est toujours la même
qu'elle soit celle de l'historien celle
de l'économie de l'économie du financier
ça se passe toujours que la même façon
les mécanismes sont toujours les mêmes
la cupidité la cupidité
oui parce que la publicité c'est la
nature humaine mais ça se passe toujours
pareil c'est à dire que on fait toujours
les mêmes erreurs
et elle reproduisent les mêmes les mêmes
conséquences tu te rends compte je vous
vous rendez compte l'inertie que notre
société a appris parce qu'on a grossi
grossi grossi le système financier a
grossi grossi grossier de plus en plus
intriqués dans tous les domaines
là la science à une les banques
centrales sont en short les dettes des
états
que de créer de la monnaie ni en ni pour
la sortir de la crise financière de 2008
ni pour gérer la pandémie le problème
c'est la façon dont on a géré la
pandémie c'est à dire à partir du moment
où vous arrêtez de vous enfermez tout le
monde et où il y a des gens qui vous
expliquent que nos nos vies valent plus
que nos profits
que ça justifie qu'on enferme tout le
monde et qu'on arrête tout
alors que l'économie c'est pas des
profils économie c'est la vie ce sont
les services que nous nous rendons les
uns aux autres
mais voilà
évidemment la facture elle est colossale
et quand vous rajoutez à ça ce qu'on
fait avec sur la sur la question de de
l'Ukraine et qu'on vous dit mais
vous allez voir c'est on va faire
s'effondrer l'économie russe
et qu'on n'a pas réfléchi un instant
au fait que d'abord quand on économie
comme ça se place en économie de guerre
la question de savoir si elle accumule
des devises
internationales ne se pose plus du tout
de la même façon qu'en plus quand vous
êtes un pays qui a autant de matières
premières mais vous pouvez très bien
vivre sans avoir beaucoup de dollars ou
de monnaie convertible parce que vous
pouvez faire des accords de troc
parce que l'idée qu'on a rien à
apprendre de l'ancien monde
c'est l'idée la plus absurde qui soit
Jérémy tu as énervé oh j'ai vécu non
mais c'est oui parce que ça c'est
tellement facile c'est tellement
d'ailleurs le le monde que nous avons
construit que nous sommes en train de
construire et on pose sur cette erreur
fondamentale consiste à dire bon moment
de pas comme le vôtre vous comprenez
ceci
c'est fantastique c'est c'est assez
extraordinaire moi j'ai vécu dans la fin
de cette période de la fin de la guerre
froide il y avait beaucoup de pays qui
n'étaient pas dépays économie de marché
on faisait des accords de garantie
d'investissement et eux comment ils
faisaient les accords de troc très
souvent très compliqué les traders ils
savent des traders de commerciaux ils
savent faire très bien faire ça ils
avaient développé des techniques
magiques
et vous croyez que les Russes ils font
pas pareil
ils ont commencé à sortir de Swift je
crois que c'est
donc ils ont une monnaie d'échange voilà
donc c'est pas si simple de dire bon je
vais vous couper je vais plus acheter
votre gaz et vous allez moi bah non
d'abord parce qu'il y a des gens qui
sont obligés de l'acheter parce que ça
fait monter le prix du gaz parce qu'il
pense les ventes qui nous font pas par
le prix du cas et de toute façon parce
que ils n'ont pas autant besoin que ça
pour le pense puisque cette problème
c'est le problème c'est un problème
psychologique et intellectuel là aussi
croire que le monde dans lequel on est
enfermé
c'est c'est la nature des choses le
financier sur son dans sa salle de
trading
le monde c'est ça c'est
c'est ça jamais été autrement le monde
mais si il a été autrement le monde
avant la cotation continue il y avait le
fixing et vous croyez vraiment que ça a
été un progrès la cotation en continu
on peut y passer des heures c'est très
intéressant moi j'étais quand on a
basculé de l'un à l'autre c'est
extraordinaire
pourquoi la valeur d'une entreprise ça
change de nanoseconde à une annonceuse
ça change pas comme ça ça change pas
trois fois par jour le fixing ça
permettait avec en général enfin souvent
un prix par jour parfois deux selon les
marchés mais ça permettait de rassembler
toutes les offres et toutes les demandes
au même moment et puis de solder le de
solder le
la différence entre les deux
ça permettait de reprendre son souffle
ça permettait ça voulait pas dire qu'il
y avait pas de crise mais ça avait été
les effets de suivi ça évite ça
éviterait bien de choses c'est pas
parfait
c'est pas il y a aucune impossibilité
voilà moi j'ai vu des gens enfin il faut
il faut arrêter de penser prenez la
taxation des transformations financière
va me dire le monde a changé c'est que
sans doute oui par exemple
moi j'ai été très frappé on avait on
avait fini par obtenir d'un G20 que que
bon si un jour on voit je me souviens
très bien d'une rencontre avec le
directeur général du FMI de l'époque
bah alors si vous avez
pas faire la différence entre la
spéculation et l'anneau spéculation mais
la taxe bobine elle fait pas la
différence entière elle n'a pas besoin
c'est quoi cet argument si le G20 avait
voulu
vraiment contact des transactions
financière et même qu'en réglemente à
nouveau les marchés financiers
techniquement c'était possible et qui a
un problème politique parce que la
moitié du G20 voulait pas très bien mais
techniquement vous dites si le G20 dit
il y a plus une transaction financière
qui sera reconnue légalement dans aucun
de nos pays si elle passe pas par un
marché organisé qu'est-ce que vous
croyez qu'on va faire les gens
ils vont faire un combat en France quand
vous achetez un appartement
vous avez chez le notaire une fois que
vous avez démarché vous n'avez plus que
des marcheurs organisés
vous pouvez taxer vous pouvez
réglementer
il y a pas d'impossibilité on peut dire
c'est pas bien on peut on peut être
contre mais dire c'est pas possible
c'est comme l'histoire du marché unique
du gaz
est-ce que ça avoir avec le Nouveau
Monde l'ancien nom mais celui qui vit à
Bruxelles qui est dans son marché unique
de l'électricité j'ai marché unique on
peut pas imaginer le monde autrement
celui qui vit dans les marchés
financiers imaginer une taxe financière
c'est pas possible c'est inimaginable
quelle est la vie de Henri Guaino le
brexit c'est bien c'est pas bien et
est-ce que le choix des Anglais moi je
est-ce qu'il faut faire un frexit non
non pour une raison c'est la question à
mon sens de ce pose pas elle se pose pas
pourquoi parce qu'il y a la monnaie
unique et que ça veut dire faire un
frexit ça veut dire sortir de la monnaie
unique
or moi je ne sais pas quelle cataclysme
peut entraîner la sortie de la mononie
qui est la même si la France sort c'est
la destruction de la deuxième monnaie du
monde
quelle est la conséquence dans un
contexte de globalisation financière de
la sortie de la monnaie unique voilà la
question moi je me sens pas
capable d'accepter moralement de prendre
un tel risque en sortant du du
de l'euro ça c'est ma première remarque
la
la deuxième c'est que
vous pouvez en sortir moi je pense que
le jour ça explosera parce que c'est une
monnaie artificielle mais si autre chose
je veux dire faut qu'il faille se
préparer dans sa tête avant d'exploser
il va bien se dévaluer oui mais ça bon
ça descend souvent oui
je pense qu'on a plus souffert de
l'horofort que de l'euro faible voilà
donc pareil pour les Allemands les
Français les Français les Allemands
aussi
les Allemands aussi mais ça sert à rien
puisque ce monde de l'âme n'a rien à
nous apprendre les Allemands le terme de
bonnetelles n'a pas de sens économique
de la monnaie les surévaluée ou
sous-évaluée les Allemands iraient
évaluer leur monnaie parce qu'ils
faisaient moins d'inflation que les
autres mais toujours en retard sur
l'audience de l'inflation donc ils ont
eu une monnaie qui était qui n'a cessé
de se en fait de se sous-évaluer ou de
se dévaluer pendant des décennies ils
ont pas du tout vécu sur une monnaie
surévaluée
c'est intéressant d'aller
de regarder ça c'est c'est
tout ça ça change pas si vous savez on
raconte n'importe quoi c'est c'est
facilement comprenez ces fantastiques
c'est c'est il y a des imbéciles qui
viennent vous raconter que le PIB de la
Russie c'est le même que celui de
l'Espagne
ouais mais quand vous le calculez en
parité de pouvoir d'achat c'est plus
pareil
or qu'est-ce qui compte
c'est le calcul parce que les économies
s'appellent la parité de pouvoir d'achat
c'est-à-dire tener en compte du niveau
général des prix dans le pays ça coûte
pas la même chose de produire ici de la
Russie qu'aux États-Unis
c'est pareil pour le budget de
l'armement chinois c'est pareil
exactement
voilà quand vous êtes ça c'est pas des
opinions ça
quand vous êtes ici parce que je
m'énerve je m'énerve pas mais je chacun
le droit d'avoir l'opinion qui veut mais
j'ai tellement vu
commettre de
fautes qui n'était pas simplement des
questions d'opinion tellement vu des
gens qui ne réfléchissaient pas qui ne
travaillaient pas se moquer du monde
finir d'ailleurs par croire à leur
propre mensonge
pour en arriver là
que j'ai parfois quelques relents
d'indignation voilà sur l'état du monde
très bien alors c'est quoi ça veut dire
quoi un nouveau monde il y aura plus de
salarié il y aura plus de tout le monde
va faire tout on va revenir au 19ème
siècle c'est bien on embauchera les gens
le matin on les virer le soir et puis
plus personne paiera de charges sociales
parce que ce sera uberisé partout et
qu'on aura pas requalifier les les
contrats du Berre par des
salariaux c'est ça le nouveau monde mais
c'est fatal
il faut s'y faire
Jérémie il a peut-être vécu dans ce
monde là mais
il y avait un monde avant et celui qui
qu'on est en train de faire celui dans
lequel il vit auquel il s'habitue c'est
le monde avant
j'étais malade et le confinement et voir
les gens faire la politique de la peur
tous les soirs
qu'est-ce qu'on fait tout ça pour faire
obéir les gens
et quand j'ai été guéri je pouvais même
pas sortir aller faire du sport respirer
parce que j'avais pas le droit de
me donner d'un kilomètre et de pouvoir
essayer de me remettre en forme de
respirer et maintenant on se rend compte
que tout ça enfin une bonne partie de
tout ce qu'on a fait c'était de cette
scientifiquement sans aucun fondement
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait qui était par
exemple le confinement c'est très
intéressant enfin c'est absent en tout
cas sans fondement scientifique moi
comme disent je sais pas quoi faire très
bien je sens tout le monde c'est bien
que c'est pas forcément mais comme dit
c'est scientifique mais c'est
fantastique regardez aujourd'hui en
France on n'a pas se débat mais aux
États-Unis
extrêmement sérieuses
pour essayer de voir ce que s'il y a des
différences entre les endroits où on a
confiné tout le monde endroit on a
confiné personne les endroits la confiné
un peu etc il y a pas on trouve aucune
différence
qu'une différence même sur les masques
même sur les masques il y a toutes les
études des masques chirurgicaux
parce qu'on nous a obligé à porter
donc
il y a des tonnes de choses donc au
moins discuter pour pas refaire les
mêmes les mêmes erreurs mais discuter
c'est pas trop le Light motif en ce
moment mais non mais
là avec son raisonnement on peut pas
discuter un virement des différents
c'est fantastique les virus ils ont quoi
ils ont changé c'est bien on est
regardez maintenant on se rend compte
que finalement
l'immunité collective c'est pas une
mauvaise idée
c'est intéressant c'est la plus vieille
idée de l'épidémiologie du monde
ah ben non ça c'est fini c'est puis
maintenant on se dit bah ouais
finalement ceux qui ont pas fait ceux
qui ont pas marié là-dessus ceux qui ont
fait la covid zéro normalement
si vous prenez son raisonnement c'est
fini
il y a plus il y a plus à penser quoi je
demande de ce qu'il est aujourd'hui bah
voilà c'est le nouveau monde c'est comme
ça
c'est
je finis sur tout ça ça fait un jour à
la télé puisque vous me dites
par la fenêtre
pendant la fin de la pandémie il y avait
un spot de santé publique France avec
les grands-parents
et après la fiche
on a le droit de discuter de tout seul
les chiffres ne se discutent pas
c'est ça c'est scientifique c'est
fantastique je veux dire seuls les
chiffres ne se discutent pas
voilà moi j'en suis resté mais halluciné
heureusement
heureusement c'est mais
c'est ça le Nouveau Monde
question Guillaume deux trois actions
phares à suggéré à la portée de tous
très bien supprimer l'âge de départ à la
retraite
les salaires
non mais apporter à la compréhension de
tous ou à la portée de tous ça veut dire
quoi la portée de touche de sa
compréhension ou de de ce qui peut faire
lui-même voilà mais moi je pense que ça
veut rien dire se faire soi-même je veux
pas refaire le monde tout seul voilà et
puis vous non plus donc
des choses à faire est-ce que vous avez
trois bouquins à conseiller à notre
communauté
des bouquins oui mais c'est des bouquins
de l'ancien monde
mais non mais c'est oui alors moi je
conseille de lire par exemple le premier
homme de Camus il a sûrement lu mais
c'est très bien voyez c'est sur ce qui
n'ont pas changé
que moi mais c'est marrant mais ce qui
lui est arrivé ça ressemble à quelque
chose que je
que j'ai vécu c'est parce que d'autres
le vivent aujourd'hui ils vivront demain
mais donc le premier homme ça fait
je pense que c'est peut-être le
capitalisme de bretelles
il y a trois évidemment dans le monde
nouveau monde c'est compliqué de lire
mais c'est dommage parce que c'est sans
doute qu'on a écrit de plus instructif
sur le capitalisme ce soit l'histoire
sur la façon voilà même si le bordel
était pas un économiste c'est
voilà après je
après des vieilles quoi je non mais
non par exemple moi je l'ai vu cinq fois
mais je pense qu'il y a
je suis pas un admirateur de du
personnage de Chateaubriand mais je
pense c'est ce qu'il a écrit de mieux et
c'est un des plus grands livres
de de la littérature française un
conseil pour les jeunes pour le pour
taquiner un peu peut-être le Mémorial de
Sainte-Hélène pas mal non plus
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
et un conseil pour les vieilles
générations pour changer
normalement j'ai deux conseils à donner
à personne
mais si j'avais une idée à leur suggérer
aux jeunes générations c'est de ne pas
croire comme notre génération l'a fait
comme la génération suivante la fait
aussi de ne pas céder à cette tentation
de croire
que de génération en génération des
meilleurs que les générations
précédentes l'homme ne s'améliore pas ni
moralement ni intellectuellement
s'améliore matériellement
un peu physiquement parce qu'ils mangent
mieux parce que
la médecine ne soigne mais
nous ne sommes pas nous sommes même pas
notre propre commencement
voilà c'est quand on est sans nous
héritons déjà
d'un tas de choses dont parfois nous
soupçonnons pas l'existence
mais qui nous détermine qui détermine
nos comportements
voilà si vous êtes né en Pologne
polonais
vous ne pouvez pas voir ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui de la même façon que si vous
êtes né en Espagne
nous sommes pas notre propre
commencement et nous avons quelque chose
à apprendre de l'histoire sur ce que
nous sommes
vous savez Malraux disait
l'humanisme c'est pas je fais mieux
que ce que ferait la bête en moi
humanisme c'est
je ne fais pas ce que la bête en moi me
dit de faire
Enrique
[Musique]